welcome everybody welcome back
happy saturday
uh this is this is gonna be quite the
stream here
we have
some very very very exciting
exciting information for you guys this
is the stream where we determine the
winners
of the parallel dimensions
contest and since
a lot of you guys are from out of
country and can only win prizes if
you're in the us i've split it up into
two pools so basically there's the the
eligible contest eligible um you know
top five winners and then for those of
you out of country i'm going to send you
guys some of my
really nice
photography art prints so even if you're
out of country i got you top three
winners um with some custom art prints
signed by me and everything so i want to
make it worth everyone's while
everyone's gonna win here today
um what's up everybody if you guys can
hear me and can see me give me some
thumbs ups because i'm in a new space if
you can't tell we just moved into a new
spot um i'm still sitting at my studio
it is kind of
halfway in the works right now so
hopefully you guys can hear me okay and
it sounds all right
yep
um
i'm excited i'm very excited for this
new spot it's gonna be a it's gonna be a
good one
so
before i jump in
and
oh low volume big thumbs i got big
thumbs
but one dude's got low volume well
george turn up your
headphones or your speaker maybe because
we got uh
we've got thumbs ups all around awesome
and my mic is kind of it's a little
further away this time so we're going to
bear with me
on this one i think i'm getting good
levels let me check this
i'm getting
halfway decent levels maybe i can crank
this up
a little bit louder for you guys
but i could also just talk louder too
and maybe get a little bit closer
so
we should make sure the autofocus is
going and yeah we got my camera set up
it's all nice
um
all right so where where else what else
are we doing yeah skillshare that's
coming i got you guys on that
um
wonderful so the next thing
i'm going to be talking about actually
the first thing i'm going to be talking
about
is how i got from concept art to the
final version of my render which you
guys can see
right here so let me see if i can pull
up
something i'll show you guys the process
because this i learned a whole lot doing
this
and i hope you guys did too
um so let's see real quick i want to
pull up all the different versions
that i rendered out while i was doing
this
so as you guys know
on the first stream we started with
concept art in volume 1 of the master
class
we made this in photoshop
and
this is the final so they're very very
similar um
you know the mountain's a little smaller
but i use this to guide
my render here
but i started with this this was the
first thing i started with on the on the
stream number two i believe volume two
is where we talked about the ground
plane
uh in the very next stream the third
stream we talked about the volcano and
we kind of built that out built out the
background a little bit added some like
steam and fog here that i think worked
out really well and we used lightning
to um to build out our lava
in the next stream we built out the
foreground you know we added these huts
and these stumps and everything but then
this is what you guys didn't see you
know throughout the week i kept working
and
added some stuff in the foreground here
changed the lighting a bit changed the
sky
and finally photo scanned myself and got
to our final image here
so i want to walk you guys through that
process
of how i did that
but
um let me let me actually show you guys
my render too i'm going to show you my
guys show you my final render
so
here inside of
let's see here
here we go
awesome
so
i got i got da vinci pulled open
and let me just show you guys my render
i have every single submission here
we're going to go through every single
one and we're going to review them and
i'm going to give you guys notes and
feedback and we're going to whittle it
down to
the top three
well i guess since we're doing two pools
there's going to be a top five
us only
and then there's going to be a top three
overall
you know
everybody every render is is included
and then i'll be sending out you guys
some uh some nice photography prints but
let me show you guys my render how the
final render turned out
i'm gonna loop it a couple times
i'm really proud of how this thing
turned out
i added a lot i spent a lot of time on
it and like i said i learned a lot too
so this is it right here
you know i got some birds up in the sky
photo scan myself
um
[Music]
added a little like stuffed animal down
here dangling from my backpack
i'm really really happy with how this
thing turned out
and getting the
smoke up here was a challenge
that was all in after effects so i'll
give you guys a breakdown of how i did
that
but first
you guys know what's coming
our sponsor for today's
live stream is skillshare let me pull
them up here boom
skillshare
so if you guys don't know by this point
you know you've been living under a rock
skillshare it's an online learning
community for creatives and artists
like you guys just for you guys it's a
place where you guys can learn something
new where you can grow your value
as a as an artist as a creator as a
person
you know skillshare is actually really
cool because you can learn literally
anything you can type into a search bar
so if you want to learn obviously you
know any 3d work
painting sculpting
you know you got all that photography
filmography you got that stuff but you
also have stuff like cooking and taxes
and
snowboarding and
maybe some rock climbing and maybe some
yoga and working out it literally has
anything it's set for any schedule
the classes are super bite-sized small
little classes
and they're set for any skill level too
so you guys can jump in no matter where
you're at
so i want to show you guys three classes
three classes that i really really think
you guys would enjoy so we're talking
you know parallel dimensions we are
doing a render contest an environment
render contest so the first place
you know i guess the whole the whole
reason i wanted to start this thing is
because i love doing photography
specifically film photography and i love
traveling to new places and
um and capturing that place and
capturing that environment
so this is a class by antonio casteo and
he walks you guys through the whole
process of
shooting film if you guys are interested
in shooting film i know i love it a
whole lot
antonio's going to walk you through the
whole thing in this small skillshare
course you know it's about an hour and a
half
you know good times over here you're
going to learn a lot
now once you take your pictures right
once i have taken all my photos and i'm
sitting home alone in quarantine
i want to create some cool stuff so like
we did in volume one of the of the
environment master class we have this
painting environments uh skillshare
course here
by hardy fowler and he walks you guys
through this dude's legit uh he walks
you through
his whole process when
creating these 3d environments or not
sorry not 3d they're done in photoshop
you know they're done in any sort of
painting program that you guys would use
and they're there to guide um your art
to the next level you know the the
concept art could be your final spot
but
you know in this case for parallel
dimensions
i use the concept art to kind of guide
my final render so this is a really nice
class for you guys to dive into here
and lastly
you're gonna have to take this concept
art and
you know transfer it to a 3d world so
the cool thing about skillshare
obviously is you can uh look up anything
so you have blender you type in blender
and there's a whole bunch of like
just starting in blender tutorials all
the way down to very specific stuff in
blender we can look up uh
cinema 4d and you can find the whole
deal if i spelled things right
yeah
but it's still got you cinema 4d it's
all up in here um so
you have
intro classes that can help you guys get
started or advanced classes patrick
foley's dude's legit he's got some good
ones
um and yeah i mean anything from
you know unreal engine
basically you can look up anything and
learn anything on on skillshare
and as a skillshare member you guys get
unlimited access to regularly updated
premium content for less than ten
dollars a month for an annual
subscription right and the first
thousand people who click the link down
below in the description
get a free trial of skillshare premium
so definitely check it out guys click
the link it helps me out for sure it
helps me do more of these streams
um so
yeah that'd be awesome we're all here to
learn we're all here to learn a thing or
two so
definitely give it a shot
but it's time
close this down
it's time to go over what went into
finishing out my render
and then we're going to get into the
submissions and the reviews and we're
going to choose the winners
here live on the stream so let me go
ahead
and open up
let's go ahead and open up after effects
because i'll work backwards here
i want to talk about the things i did to
bring this piece of art together
um
you know there was there was a lot of
small subtle stuff that's going on to
make this look
um
like it does you know a lot of subtle
color correction and and a lot of work
was spent getting this smoke right up in
the mountains i could still work on it
but i ran out of time i wanted to
spend just the amount of time you guys
had on it so i kind of cut myself off
but i might tweak it a little uh
a little later in the week because we're
going to put together that whole render
um you know awesome montage and i
actually got
a good friend of mine casey edwards he
is putting together some music for it he
sent me a little sample of what he was
doing last night and
it's gonna be awesome it's gonna be
freaking cool
so let's go ahead and open up my project
file for this piece of art here
and give you guys the breakdown of what
went into this i'll open up cinema as
well
we can kind of work backwards and get
into that
but i just want to spend the next 15 20
minutes talking to you guys about the
process
what's up everybody everyone's in the in
the house today we got tinum
with cg kiwi what's up what's going on
a lot of y'all hanging out zspc
loving loving him some skillshare
awesome i'm glad it's nice to see you
guys you know using the stuff that i uh
that i talk about you know the sponsored
stuff
it it makes it feel like it's not some
random product you know
so that's cool all right so this is the
final the final image here
let me just toggle on some of this stuff
to show you what's going on so
we're starting with
just the image just the render this is
the final render
minus the smoke which i did later and
same for the birds
what i'm doing here is i'm giving this
uh
on the lake here on this reflection just
a little bit of orange
reflection from the mountain in the
background and i'm using
basically uh
the render
crunched down let me see if i can turn
this on
solo this
so i'm using the extract
uh filter basically not filter and it's
not a plugin the effect the extract
effect which you can basically slide up
and down to
reveal dark or bright parts of your
image and it kind of keys it out so it
stays on alpha i love it it's the best
so i'm using that as an alpha matte
to show this orange you know
bit of of light
to reveal that mountain in the
background just a little bit
we got some color correction i think
some very subtle color correction that's
just lumetri color with a white balance
on the clouds
gives it more of a greenish tinge
and then i'm coming in and making the
the sky a bit darker here
um just a really soft selection kind of
a vignette going on and then i do have a
vignette
around the image subtle i don't want to
go too intense with it
and then finally i don't know what this
is
oh this is just a bit of sharpening so
right at the end i just like to sharpen
it just a little bit
so let's keep working backwards all
right so what came out of cinema 4d was
this right here
all right
so if i just you know
scrub this wow that's really
really low res
so yeah this is what came out of cinema
4d most of the work i put into this art
was in c4d
and we'll go ahead and open that up and
dive in and talk about how i did that as
well just a brief overview
oh the camera is over the layers thank
you
appreciate y'all thank you thank you
so
this is what came out of c4d
and then i just start building building
things up and building things up
we have some lingering smoke i'm using
action v effects
and a z depth pass that i rendered from
cinema
as a luma mat
to put that fog
in front of me basically because this is
a photo scan of me
and you know i'm dropping a couple other
little fog layers in there just to just
to spice it up a little bit and kind of
blend
the foreground and mid ground into the
background because i didn't like
this line i kind of saw a line there so
i was like you know what let's just kind
of
give it a little bit of something a
little bit of movement in there
um moving on i'm still using the z depth
layers that i rendered from cinema to
give me a bit more fog
so i'm i really hated the top of this
mountain a whole lot
it just didn't look good didn't look
good at all so i'm like i gotta cover it
up a little bit so i just sampled the
sky color
and dropped that in as like a feathered
little bit
with some z depth on it
just to cover it up a little bit more
and now what we have here
are three layers of smoke from action
vfx
and i'll go one at a time and i'm just
feathering out the bottom so they kind
of just disappear into the mountain
and then i drop one a little bit lower
because i again i hated how
the top of that mountain hit the sky
like that i just didn't like it at all
so i'm trying to cover that up
but that still doesn't look good it
needs something it needs light the light
needs to
shine from inside the smoke
so i did a cool little trick here at
least i think it's a cool little trick
um
as i started bringing in
basically some light from the inside and
what i did and how i did that
let me bring these up for you
so like this it looks like it's glowing
from inside
all i did was duplicate the smoke layer
i wanted to look like it was glowing
and i dropped
let me see if i can
solo just this
bit
and i'm using the extract plug-in or not
god not plug-in i got something the
extract effect so this is just the smoke
and with the extract i'm pulling out all
the bright parts so this
slider pulls out all the bright parts
and leaves me with just the dark parts
which are the most internal part of the
smoke
right
so with that i'm saying use this use
this layer right here
as an alpha matte for
an orange
kind of
uh
you know it's it's basically just an
orange card
and it's just in side of the dark parts
of the smoke
so that gets you overlaid on top
and gets you the appearance or the
feeling that the the smoke is being lit
from underneath and it's a it's a real
cool like cheat
on how to do that in 2d versus doing it
in 3d which i i was not equipped for
um
and
eric what's up dude thank you for the
super chat thank you for the kombucha
money
um i find a lot of value in these weekly
streams never stop
dude thank you so much man that's
awesome i'm really glad you enjoy them
and i hope they just keep getting better
and better man i hope we all can keep
learning together
i'm gonna grab a kombucha soon my throat
is already hurting
but we're gonna keep going we're gonna
keep talking about how this came
together um
[Music]
so let me
get back here i'm gonna solo these
things so we can keep building it up one
building block at a time so we have
that internal glow layer
and a little bit more i just did it with
a white card instead so it's white and
those are both set to like add probably
yep so it's glowing even
hotter from the inside
and then i realized based off my concept
art there's a big red glow
cast by this lava so i need to
start adding some you know some 2d light
effects and start faking
this this glow
because this mountain or this volcano
would be casting a glow on the fog and
the the clouds around it
so i got to fake it
and i'm doing that with just you know a
red solid
feathered out the opacity drop down
um
but closer to the center of that volcano
i got an orange card here which is just
feathered out you know and it's tighter
the mask is tighter around the central
point of the volcano so the glow is
getting hotter and brighter
and i'm using z depth mats
as alphas here
but they're not really doing much to be
honest
so you don't have to worry about that
and then
what i'm doing is i'm actually using the
extract filter
the extract effect again
to just get me
these uh
the lava flow bits here
and i'm bringing those out in front of
the smoke in front of the fog
and i'm blurring them out
at different amounts to get more and
more of a glow so that's without
and that's width and that
really really really starts to come
together now it brings it together and
i'm working in 32 bits if i was not in
32 bits
um let's see if i was not in 32 bits the
glow wouldn't be as hot like that if i
went to 8 bit
it looks horrible
it's actually gone which is pretty
insane
um
only in 32-bit was i getting that look
so
that helped out a lot
moving on we have some birds
flying about so if i scrub to the middle
at some point here
where are you guys there they are
they're way over there so what i did is
i i literally just used my iphone
and i filmed some birds going up in the
sky this is a cleaned mat but basically
i filmed some birds up in the sky with
my iphone i used the uh basically a luma
mat so i made it black and white with
tint crushed the levels to get it to
look black and white like this so the
birds are black
and the background's white and i just
set it to multiply
and now i have some realistic looking
birds flying up in the sky i didn't want
to simulate those because it would just
take forever
so
you know they're up in there doing their
thing and i have a bunch of different
layers of those guys
flying around
doing the bird dance
and the birds really were like an added
thing that brought it all together
um it made it feel a bit more realistic
and it gave it a bit more um scale and
depth right
and i noticed some of you guys put birds
into your renders which i thought was
awesome
so that was basically all that was
coming into this when it comes to after
effects so let me open up c4d
and i'll talk to you guys real quick
about this photo scan i did
um
and the building blocks that went into
the environment everything we we talked
about it all on the past streams if you
guys
want to catch that and want to watch me
do it definitely go back i got the 3d
environment master class volume one two
three and four
where we build out this whole thing
right here
um
so yeah i'll talk to you guys about the
photo scan i did
i scanned myself with um
with my buddy cliff
and i went into an a pose which is t
pose is your arms teed out and a pose is
uh you know your hands down into a
little a shape
all right
let's open this up
so i'll just open up my photo scan
and this thing
when i first
you know
did the scan it had like a million
polygons no no way more than a million
polygons
way more than a million polygons it was
rough um and i had to
basically lower the amount of polygons
on this thing until it looks like this
and i'm not the biggest like photo scan
guy i don't know that much but i'm
getting these weird errors like this
which doesn't look right it's not right
but i got lucky because from a distance
this is totally fine
and i just had to make it work you know
yeah this mean like my hiking gear
ready for an adventure
obviously inspired by desk training
with the final render
but yeah i got this i used reality
capture to
to scan it brought it into c4d cleaned
it up
and let me see if i can open up
uh
it attached to the rig
and this is where i actually learned a
whole lot
so i have it attached to the rig and
it's moving i got my little penguin on
there too
originally
this
uh
sleeping sack here
was stretching
with my hips and i didn't like that so
what i had to do was i actually had to
go into my model
turn off the skin
and i messed with the
character the weight tool
i've never used the weight tool before
but if i right click
let's see if i
yep go here i can start painting the
weights and the issue is that you know
my leg
if i right click here and i say okay
that's hips
this is just attached to the hips
it got to the point where like
the legs were moving
the where are you legs
they're in here somewhere
anyway you guys get the idea you see
these like wherever there's a color
that's what moves the actual mesh and
when i selected my leg it was moving
this this knapsack back here
so i had to just basically repaint the
weights and then it actually worked and
it wasn't influencing my legs weren't
influencing that you know it looked
it was definitely wrong and the render
wouldn't have looked right with it
because you're staring right at it
now let me open up the final the final
image for you guys parallel dimensions
version 1r
we got down to r that's the furthest
i've been so far
this is it
yeah this is the scene
um
i mean again you guys know i scattered
these trees i bought some from cg
traders scattered scattered around the
mid ground there
got some mega scans stumps scattered
about i'm using
octane scatter to scatter a bunch of
different plants and like little
bits of clover and leaves so i'm
scattering these guys around
which you can see
you know down here off onto the sides
and whatnot
so that's all mega scans and octane
scatter objects
yep i'm dropped in here for the ground
i'm using
rd textures real displacement textures
and then for
the actual
the puddles i'm using dizzy viper's
puddle pack basically to split up the
mud and the the reflected water
um these huts i also got from i got from
turbosquid they're super cheap like 10
to 15 bucks each dropped them in dropped
a light in there
and just bounced it pushed it into the
back
um
yeah we got the fog cards going back
here and lots of different fog so i'll
show you guys that
basically
fog
yeah so all this fog you can see these
fog cards
which
it's a cheat way it's a quick way to do
fog which is basically just a gradient
set on the
the opacity channel for the material
and it's just set to like white or
something and it's the opacity is
lowered so you get some
some nice fog in there um you guys can
see the difference if i pull
up um
these guys so it's the difference
between this and this
so this is with the fog cards in
real nice and fast way to do that
and it goes all the way into the
background it really like goes off
into the background and then you have of
course your volumetric fog
uh your octane volumetric fog
which are just
you know i got some here in the
foreground and
i then there's some in the background no
there's none in the background it's all
just right in the foreground
but the fog is really what brings this
whole thing together for me it blends
everything it gives it depth it makes it
look nice
yeah so these sticks are octane scatter
with these giant trees
to give you you know these trees in the
back
um
and yeah the mountain itself for the
lava we used lightning in photoshop we
made an image
if i can pull this up for you guys lava
map
we use this image here which we created
in photoshop and there's just a bunch of
different like lightning pieces that we
dropped over the mountain to reveal an
emissive
uh an emissive texture on the mountain
in the background
and then i just used an hdri image from
[Music]
hdri haven
in the back here and i went through just
a bunch of different versions and i made
sure to pull like five or six different
looks
to really make sure i was getting the
right look that i wanted um and i ended
up going with this look right here which
i thought totally worked
um
i mean that's about it
christian
dude thank you thank you for the super
chat yes i'm going to be on the extra
live stream as soon as this stream is
done i'm going to have lunch and i'm
going to go down to corridor and i'm
going to join them for some video games
uh 3 to 5 p.m pacific standard time is
my time block
all right
so
i hope you all are having a good time i
know i'm having a good time i'm i'm
really glad this is a very uh
celebratory
stream here because i'm done we're all
done we all turned in our renders it's
gonna it's looking really really nice
so
before i move on
um i'm gonna ask you guys is there any
other questions you have
on my process with this
is there anything that you want to know
that i didn't talk about
um specifically here we can maybe spend
another five minutes on this and then
we're gonna get into
breaking down all of the the submissions
reviewing them giving my critiques on it
what could make it better what i think
you did a good job
and then we're going to work all the way
up to the winners
and announce the winners to give the
prizes away and ship you guys some cool
prints and ship you guys some graphics
cards a quadro card and uh
some ssds and some
what is a an nvidia shield tv pro and
some
you know some uh
usb 3.0 or is it 3.1 flash drives all
from nvidia and pny they're hooking it
up
yep i got my a7r ii hooked up
it's a good time we need a new place
all right
kombucha money heck yeah thank you
christian i'm gonna grab some in a
second before we get to these
submissions
um
[Music]
all right for my birds um
birds are flying
to the mountain but it is unreal because
they have they fly towards the camera
to escape from the volcano uh i see that
would that's a good note that's a good
note they would be flying towards the
camera that's a that's a legit note
i think that would make it like point
one percent better i agree with you
all right
what else do we have materials on my
character so the materials on the
character it's a photo scan so let me
let me show you
the photo scan
real quick
this is the material it's one material
believe it or not this is the material
that makes up
my character
um
insane huh
it's really crazy
but it's all pieced together because
there's just so many polygons and it
makes up the character i just gave it
the uh
basically i gave the character
uh a glossy kind of layer so it reflects
the environment around just a little bit
more that's it that is literally it
i cranked the roughness just a bit so
it's not like super sharp
you can see it here it doesn't look like
the best here but when it's in context i
think it looked really nice
um dig the classic teal and orange
colors 80s 90s yeah favorite sci-fi
absolutely
um
from
from what you start build composition i
started with the concept art
and i used photoshop to make the concept
art
and we ended up with this
at the end of stream one
to guide my render process
um what else do we got here
shape no problem man got you with that
skillshare premium membership
um the rig in the animation is from
mixamo yes i used a mixamo and i
actually just uploaded my model to
mixamo
and i chose um you know the points and
mixmo auto rigs your character and then
you can just plug it into you know
whichever rig you want
um
oh okay good question what do you ever
what do you do if you don't like
something in your render i'm assuming
but you can't tell what it is
that's
i mean you ask someone you ask someone
for advice
so that's what i did actually i asked um
there's a guy his name his name's eitan
zana and he is
the i think i believe he was the lead
concept artist for last of us too
and we've been talking a little bit on
instagram
and i sent him my image my render one of
one of the like close to final versions
and he said
you know the biggest thing that i'm
feeling is that these huts in the
foreground take away from the mountain
in the background it confuses the
silhouette
so he said he'd push them in the back
which is why i pushed them back further
and i think it really added it really
it made it better it really made it
better so shout outs to aton um your
work is incredible so it was amazing to
hear that from him
and uh
the same to you guys if you guys don't
know what's wrong with your render
that's the whole reason why i have a
discord server the link is also in the
description you can go there sign up i
mean you don't sign up you just just hop
in it doesn't cost anything
um and you know we have a bunch of
different channels
for you know you guys needing advice and
ideas on the renders that you're putting
out
and you know we had this parallel
dimensions work in progress channel
where you guys helped each other out it
was so cool it was so freaking cool
so yeah ask for help that's what i would
do
how do you make a photo realistic well a
lot goes into it a lot goes into that
i think it's lighting and i think it's
the way you set up your environment
obviously nature works in a very
specific way so you need to study nature
a little bit
study your reference use your reference
color correct your shots
i think that those things help
definitely double your edges
that definitely helps
i used qixel bridge and mixer or no
sorry not mixer just bridge
um
any other questions before we jump into
the submissions
why do i use after effects beta because
rotobrush too
that's the only reason
how do you how do you choose footage for
linear 32-bit workflow is it possible to
seamlessly combine 8-bit fog and 32-bit
footage so what i did with my birds
because the birds
were all weird when i switched to
multiply in 32-bit is i just saved out
the birds
and brought them back in
how i wanted them so i kind of was like
saving things rendering things bringing
them back into the 32-bit workflow to
make sure it looked nice and worked out
so that's kind of how i got around that
i think that's it
on which channel will corridor stream um
it's gonna be the node channel
yeah we're doing an extra life charity
stream natalie's putting that together
but uh i'll be joining those guys at 3
p.m after my stream here after we get
through these submissions so here's what
i'm gonna do guys i'm gonna go run and
grab a kombucha real quick and then
we're gonna hop into
all of these submissions
and we're going to review them and we're
going to choose our winners you can see
i have them all lined up
right here we got a lot
but we're going to get through it and
it's going to be super fun i'm excited
so uh literally like a minute uh evolver
yo what's up dude
thanks for joining and thanks for the
super chat i really appreciate i always
appreciate you and um
you know you're super helpful dude so
thank you very very much it means a
lot um okay i'm gonna grab a drink and
we're gonna do this we're gonna talk
about
all these submissions and pick our
winners
be right back
thank you
so
all right let's do this
are you all ready
are y'all ready
so here's what i'm gonna do here's how
we're doing this
i'm going to go through all these
and i'm going to
use my little video layer tracks here
to start pulling up
renders that are that make it to the
next level essentially
and it's going to work like that we're
going to keep just
pulling up renders make it to the next
level
until we get to the top
and that's how it's going
down right sodamonte welcome
he's the number one mod he's up in here
crushing it um mod in the chat modding
the discord server
doing a really really good job
let's dive into it guys
so
we'll zoom in we go let's go all the way
in
all right first one let's take a look
full screen
okay okay
so that's the first one
the very very first one
how do we let's see is there a better
way i can do this like
uh maybe if i set my in and out points
and will it loop
it won't loop
maybe it's just because i don't know da
vinci well enough
maybe if you guys know the answer you
can help me out
all right so
dang i really wish i really wish it
would just loop
that is what i need um there's got to be
a way to do this
replace clip
maybe hit the loop button
next to fast forward yeah
what
i definitely thought that would work
evolver yo thanks again man appreciate
it
heck yeah super chats
are for you also so keep keep them
coming
absolutely man absolutely we're doing it
every single week
i definitely thought that loot button
would work didn't i
oh that's what we'll do we'll double
click the clip
yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's the way to do it
boom okay so yeah here we go for
submission
pretty sweet pretty sweet um
what am i seeing here okay
so
it almost looks like the world has
flipped up the world has definitely
flipped upside down um it's like a
crystal lake kind of scenario going on
um with these like weird gassy
water puffs flying up into the sky
um
i think the silhouette it's it's a
little crazy it's a little all over the
place when i squint my eyes like there's
a lot going on i really like your your
town in the background though i think
this is cool
um and
you know this like factory thing looks
cool up here i just think this stuff in
the foreground the water stuff is a bit
busy
it's a bit crazy um but good job you put
a cloak on the character in the
foreground walking on this bridge
all right
i got you okay
let's go to the next one
what do we got here this one is insane
oh man i wish i could full screen oh god
okay hold on we're gonna figure this out
um
yeah i guess this can't go full screen
unless you guys know how to make this go
full screen and just loop this bit
oh nope that's working all right sweet
okay so this one is a little a little
crazy you definitely have some intense
stuff going on in the background here
um
that to me feels a little intense a
little intense
but i do like your colors here your aqua
colors you got your blue um there's some
sort of eyeball up in the sky here
i don't know what these guys are they're
like
statue people
um and a gate
the biggest thing on this one is the sky
is going all nuts on me if it's
distracting it's really distracting um
you know and it's hard to tell what
these like statue lake guys are doing so
i would just go for a bit more clarity
um i don't know if this is glitched out
or what um
but yeah i would just try and clean it
up just clean this up a little bit um
render some higher samples i think it
gets a little pixelated towards the end
not quite sure what's going on there
um
i don't know where i am
that's the thing i don't know where i am
where is this
uh so maybe maybe define that a little
bit more i don't know if this is water
or if this is a lake i just had a lot of
i have a lot of questions i don't have
anything to ground myself the only thing
i have to ground myself on this one is
this gate right here in this person
everything else i'm not sure what it is
so that would be
my my advice would be to more clearly
define where we're at
um and and what's going on and what's
your reference what are you using for
reference
i get you
i got you
oh man you messed up the keyframe for
this guy
dude
it's all kept
but it's still it still goes it still
goes to show okay
where are we what's going on here um i
just need those answers i need the i
need those things i answered just a
little bit
um because i don't know where i am are
we in an alien planet are we in space or
in a computer i don't know is this water
is this fog but it's all good man you
freaking put this thing together that's
that's another thing too guys like yeah
there's going to be renders that are
better than other people's because we
simply have either had more time to work
on it or we had more experience going
into it so guys don't worry don't get
down about if your render is good or bad
or whatever
the point is
hopefully we all learned something when
we did this all right guys so
it's all it's all fair game guys don't
worry about it
all right moving on moving on
let's go in
oh this one's nice this one is super
nice
let's pull it up let's talk about it
yeah double-click
and we loop it and we're in
yeah this one's cool
this one is amazing
wow okay this one is amazing all right
so you got your gandalf kind of guy
going down like there's just so much
going on i love it so much in a good way
you got a little wormy worm man
uh rolling up you got some like
uh
he looks like an eggplant and a
translucent eggplant
sneezing while he's fishing you know
he's fishing super hard for something
look at that
um and it goes up to his little
little uh hidey hole up here and you've
got some floating islands like dude this
is so cool
i really love this one a whole lot
uh butterflies you have particles in the
air which adds a lot of like uh it adds
depth certainly you have your fog going
up the mountain i love this
it reminds me of like fortnite colors
and stuff it's very colorful very very
playful i
love this um a whole lot
i think this is really really nice
so
what would i do to make it better
i don't know
barely anything
maybe render it more samples it's a
little uh
a little
a little noisy over here on the left
side
but man your composition rocks
really nice
this is fantastic work here um
yeah you got clouds you're in space
it's just really good
animated water mushrooms
everything this one
moves up
to the next level all right
so moving
on
we got this guy here success
now i'm not gonna i'm not gonna get the
names down i can't get everyone's names
because
not everyone's name is in their title
which wasn't
something you had to do but it certainly
helps
um
let's go ahead and run this one
so it literally just started raining
outside
um while i'm doing this
and it's raining here all right cool um
you got a character
going towards a mountain
with a giant success
all right so this one overall vibes uh
not bad not bad
i think the biggest
thing for me on this one is the lighting
[Music]
and the color
you know the mountain feels unfinished
the mountain feels unfinished
um
it's just one green texture
you know i like what you're doing with
the trees here in the foreground and you
got some rocks and dirt here in the
foreground and you got some rainy
texture it feels really nice it just
feels like you put all of your work into
the foreground and then it kind of fell
off into the background
um
you know
which is okay
i just think this needs a bit more work
your character you know you didn't have
time to switch out the character you
threw like the
glowy kind of look on it which is cool
you know you have the reflection in the
water
it's nice
um but when i look at this i just see
success
you know scribbled on the mountain and
this guy going towards it i don't really
look at the environment too much so i do
a good work on the lightning though i
think that's pretty sweet i think that's
a cool idea with the lightning it looks
like you have some
uh an animated particle system with
cloudlets in the sky but
you're cloudlet you can see the edge
so you definitely need to clean that up
and and the the rain has no motion blur
it looks like uh
it needs some sort of motion blur or at
least reference of what rain looks like
here
but i feel like this is one that just
needs a bit more work you know your
the the furniture and school signs the
uv is a little off on that um
but again i hope you learned something
when you did this so keep keep it up
keep going
all right moving on to the next one
all right this one
what's going on here
so it looks like some snowman
snowman battle
pretty pretty cool yeah you got a knight
look at the sword it's like
and his hand
what's going on here
the the like the the arms aren't
connected with the hand and the sword's
floating around
and the dude's barefoot man you go get
frostbite immediately
and then it looks like you have some
snowman in the mountain
or something um
he's walking towards a portal and
there's like a bridge here i guess these
are
like the sides of the bridge maybe
and then you got some snowy foreground
action going on it's nice you added the
particles very very nice um you know
your lighting is
is not bad it's just very white it's
very very white
um and i'm i'm missing stuff on the
sides
uh in the the blue and the orange on the
snowman it pops so much it's like boom
in your face
um i feel like this this one needs a
little bit more work as well
you know i'd probably just add a bit
more detail um
and i think i think for me it's the fact
that the whole environment is white and
then the things that stick out is like
this top hat
the character these
gray
cards here that i don't quite know what
they are
the sword sticks out a lot
so really all i'm seeing is like a hat
these gray things
some swords and this guy going towards a
mountain
so i need a again i need a bit more
visual clarity visual um you know kind
of adjustments on this to see what's
going on to guide my eye throughout this
world but
the snow looks nice it feels cold it
feels super cold so good job on that
really really good job on that
all right
moving on
to the next one
[Music]
all right yo this one before i even get
into this this one
is going up
this one steps up
that's what i'm looking for i'm looking
for that like oh
oh that's nice
and then
it levels up you know you get i wish i
had a level up sound i just got this
stream deck so i'm gonna be figuring
this thing out too
but this is awesome this is so cool um
yeah love it great work on the
environment
really cool with uh what is this zeus
hitting his trident and changing it from
day to night that's so cool
i love your animated fog cards that are
scrolling past i feel like i'm up in the
mountains that is awesome
so cool
um the way you built out the environment
i think is great
it's constructed very well it's
symmetrical
um there's a lot of iv growing up the
sides of these
columns i think that is awesome i love
it and
yeah
like this is this is super cool man this
is really really nice
definite fan you went in and you changed
out the character good job
you know or at least you parented things
to the character
uh the legs look like you switched that
out
really good work this is super cool i
like this a lot so like i said you get
to level up
next one
we
guess the level up
moving on moving on
sweet
this is
this is super cool um we got a space man
walking towards
some sort of like bio
dome
it's in a cube
so cool
i love your
your tree shader going on here this
feels very lush and you have a waterfall
with some fog
really nice
really really really nice
um
looking at the reflection it looks like
you have an hdri maybe that's some sort
of like reflection of the hdri you have
this giant ship that's pulling away
it's really cool like it's really really
really cool i think you can go even more
detailed
on your ship there's a guy named paul
chadhison i think and he does these big
ship renders
um definitely look at his work because
this is like the vibe i'm getting paul
chad heason
i think it's paul chattison
i think that's his name pretty sure
that's his name
um but this is awesome yeah i really
like your anamorphic kind of lighting
here your glare you got some uh some
flaring
with these giant afterburners
super cool maybe this is like
humanity leaving
space world or something i don't know
but yeah i dig this you changed out the
character costume your lighting's your
space lighting is solid space lighting
is kind of hard to get but you got it so
yeah you get the level up moving on
we got candy town let's take a look at
candy town
all right this one
whoa all right
hold on hold on
man this one's kind of scary
if i was trapped in this candy world i'd
be terrified
it reminds me of a couple things reminds
me of candyland obviously
and that mario kart uh
that mario kart level what is it candy
candy world or something
um
yeah this one's creepy certainly creepy
the one thing i'm not getting from this
is us is like uh
basically
what's the best way to say this um your
composition right so i'm looking at your
composition and it feels very flat
so fog would help this um
or just if you squint your eyes and you
look at the silhouette what silhouette
am i seeing it's kind of all over the
place
so it's a bit much it's certainly a bit
much i like your lollipop shader i think
that looks really nice
um but it's hard to tell are these
pancakes
probably
i don't know what this is the mountain
texture is very low res
um i like the way the candy canes like
swirl down to these other little candies
here that's fun
uh your candy cane man is awesome super
creepy
i love it
um but yeah the silhouette i'm really
having a hard time with
defining
you know
i know where i am at least i'm in some
candy
world
some crazy candy world
um
but yeah what's lacking for me is i
think the lighting
uh
and just the way it's visually set up
the composition i feel like is lacking
on this one and you know your mountain
texture is
super low res and everything
but hey as long as you learn something
that is the point so i hope you had a
fun time doing it
but yeah this is cool this is cool
candy world
moving on
to the next one
this one i'm a big fan of
i love this one
in breath of the wild when you go to the
gerudo
is it the grudo valley area the desert
place reminds me of that for sure
which was like
it's hard to say but i think that's like
my favorite area i just love how chill
this feels
you have these giant drapes blowing in
the wind
this feels so relaxing like i'm sure
it's so hot out right now but you're in
this pool and it's just the best
this is awesome i love this so much your
lighting is really nice you changed out
the character
really well done the the clothing on
this guy is really good your colors are
great
uh big fan of this one
i love
the plants and everything like the
plants if you didn't have the plants
it would have been like half as good but
the plants make it feel so awesome i
love it
yeah this is great
this is really nice you made this like a
giant uh like pyramid sand thingy
man yeah i love this one love this one
it's
leveling up
sweet
all right damon smith you're next
what you got for us damon
ooh i wanted to be a jet fighter pilot
when i was a kid but then i found out i
was color blind
so that was lame
oh man i mean this booch this booch gets
me
all right
so
i dig this one i think it's really well
done your render quality is very nice
the mountain in the background looks
really good
and your character
in the foreground i dig him i think he
looks cool you know you got the you
changed out the clothes you did the
character all nice
jets are looking cool
um
yeah time of day is really nice i like
it i certainly like it now what would i
do to make this better um
[Music]
i think your jet i mean
the jet
could be more detailed like it just feel
it feels um
i don't know too smooth i guess i think
a little bit more detail can go into the
jets
the paint on the runway is a little red
little low res right here um
so a little bummed on that your pipe
here is a little
like i know you needed something there
the pipe kind of works it leads the eye
towards the mountain definitely
um but it needs some like surface
imperfections
um i think you could have filled this
out maybe a little bit more maybe
there's like a cart like a fueling cart
that goes right here or something
um
[Music]
but i like your sky i like you have the
fog in the foreground and everything
i think this is pretty solid
i'd say this gets the level up
congrats damon smith now egypt we're
getting there's like a bunch of
different versions of the egypt one
and i cannot tell if they change or not
um
it's hard to say
but you the egypt one already got the
level up
so
i'm gonna just move on to the next one
all right
this
all one let's pull this up let's do it
right
this one is crazy this one feels like i
i like just glitched out and i got tran
i'm like being transported to another
place
i like how simple it is very simple
um the character is a little fuzzy he
looks like a bee man
he's covered in
bees
this almost looks like some some album
art honestly
um and i think you have
your ground is moving a little it's hard
to tell though
i think this is just a little too
i want to say plain
um
i think it could be cleaned up a little
bit it feels like it's glitchy in some
areas like in a in the bad way you know
like i'm seeing this like stepping on
the mountains up here um and it looks
like there's a lot of noise up in the
sky
but yeah i mean i think the color is
cool i think if you did a square cut out
like right here that could be sweet
album art
but yeah i think
i think that's all i have to say about
this one um
yeah it's very techy
very techy maybe you could do some like
waveform
oh okay you could do a wireframe mode on
the ground maybe on the sides to give it
a little bit more of something that's
probably what i would do
um
[Music]
and change out maybe like switch some
colors on and off or something could be
sweet too
yeah good work good work
oh this one this one is interesting
let's take a look
you got a moose man walking towards a
giant spider
in the background
um yeah good work on all the shrubbery
and foliage and stuff that's a lot of
work to be done right there
and then you have these fireflies up in
the sky you know that adds a lot of
depth to the image
you got your fossil this is a scary
place that's another thing is like where
am i where am i in this world is this
some skyrim place is this some dark
souls place like i don't quite know
where i am
but it's a place you know there's plants
and there's water and there's a guy and
there's a very scary spider in the
background
um
i would have added maybe a little bit
more fog in the back but you know me i'm
all about the fog
but this is cool you know oh here's
here's something i'm missing is this
giant fossil in the background these
trees are blocking it i wish you would
have pulled down the trees so i could
see this guy a little bit more so this
looks like a giant land like a
um
place of giant creatures or something
good work on the moon yeah i think
that's solid but i'm i want to see that
fossil back there you switch out the
character get really creepy vibes from
that which is good
um this one gets the level up
good work
all right
moving on owen
let's see how far we are dang all right
we maybe we need to move a little faster
we're in it though we're in it for the
long haul all right
this is awesome
super nice lots of detail went into this
i like your mountain in the back
it's a better better job than i did on
the mountain i couldn't for the life of
me figure out how to get like rock to
grass to
that's the biggest thing for me is the
mountain i spent too much time in the
foreground of mine
but this is cool man you got a lot of
moss hanging from the trees and stuff
built out the foreground a whole lot put
a detail into it
i love it
i really do i think this is good
you're gonna get the level up man
you're gonna get the level up
i like it a lot
oh my goodness
you know i'm reacting like i've seen
these for the first time i've seen all
these
but this is freaking great dude this is
amazing
um
yeah you got a custom sim going on on
the right side
i really really like your composition it
feels really nice
i love your character you change that
out i love your lighting the lighting
feels really good
definitely on some alien planet i'm
getting those vibes the only thing that
bugs me about this one is the low res um
like planet
the low-res sky that's the only thing
that bugs me about it
but you have some really good atmosphere
look at this atmosphere that's coming in
here
dude that is amazing
really nice i love these work lights
going off into the background a crashed
ship
um
it looks like these bunkers go off into
certain areas i love this this gets the
level up
easy
easy level up
all right next
all right interesting interesting so
this is another one like where am i
i think i'm in space is that the iss
flying by i think so um the sky
is a little intense it's a little
intense um flying around
and there's a lot to look at you know
the shooting star is blasting all over
um
i like your character you switch out the
character nice and i love these statues
really really cool
um
the thing for me is i feel like the
lighting the lighting is making it
difficult for me to focus on one thing
you have a lot of lights you have this
the like orange lights over here you
have
the light in the in the pool down here
you have the light back here is
different it looks like that's almost an
image
pasted
in um
and this giant spotlight so there's a
there's a lot going on in this one
um
that i think it can just be cleaned up
but i like your foreground i think you
spent a lot of time on the foreground
and it looks really really nice
yeah oh that's a mega scans tree right
there i recognize that tree all right
let's get the level up on that
ooh wee all right
ronin
let's talk all right
very cool very very cool
um
yeah we got this like aztec dude headed
towards a mountain in the back
um
not bad you got the leaves going in the
foreground just gives it some depth
hmm okay
i think your lighting is good
i think it's your your sky your
background is what's getting me it's a
little low res
and it feels weird it feels like i think
this is a situation where you need some
fog you need some atmosphere going off
into the back because it looks like this
mountain is really close to him
and
you need some distance between this guy
and the mountain
the mountain feels like it's a miniature
mountain it feels tiny so i think
giving it some atmosphere
between the character and the mountain
would really help
and i think you could probably play with
your lighting a little bit more too
and put some areas of shade where you
want to
bring out maybe like you know this
building right here you can shade the
trees behind it or something
you know stuff like that helps
and i feel like this is like squished
flat a little bit
and crunched down
but
i'm certainly getting a feeling from
this so i think it's i think it's good
and i think it deserves the level up
so let's do that
oh my goodness
this one
this one's incredible
it looks like a movie it looks like
interstellar
i mean do we even need to get into this
um
[Music]
look at those clouds man like that's
what i'm talking about that's not a low
res sky that is legit your fog through
the trees is incredible
this building is super cool makes me
want to know what's going on these
buildings up here makes me want to ask
what's going on the ship i see just
enough of it to be like i want to see
more of this
this is so cool like your trees the
placement everything
moving on you get the level up
dude
visual
oh my god
oh my goodness
look at this look at this
this
is yeah obviously gets the level up
um
look at that ground mist
that is nice
i'm really feeling something when i see
this
i feel the atmosphere it feels cold but
at the same time i like i want to be
here at the same time and what is this
giant snake in the background dude that
is out there
oh my goodness great work on your
environment great work on your lighting
great work on the composition great work
on use of atmosphere great work on the
character love it
great work all around like you got
temples going up into this thing
i'll get back to that one it's getting
the level up for sure
all right next one
all right pretty cool pretty cool um i
like your trees i think the trees look
really nice
i love your character i think that
turned out really good your mountain
textured nicely and your sky good work
really good work i see a little bit of
atmosphere and fog in there i think
that's nice
um the fence
creepy i get creepy vibes with the fence
here the only thing that is lacking for
me on this one is maybe a little bit of
contrast and dynamics in the lighting
itself i'd love to see some like
sunlight peeking through and just
hitting like a certain part
of your image like maybe it's your
character maybe it's the mid ground with
the trees back there
um
my biggest gripe is the the grass in the
foreground it's too uniform and it's not
moving it's not blowing in the wind
um and i'd love to see a bit more grass
on the corners built up in the corners
of this fence structure here
i feel like it's missing something i
feel like you need to keep working a
little bit more on the fence like
what was happening here what kind of
zone is this um
it reminds me of
the movie
stalker
really good movie
where
he's like russian
a scientist and an artist a writer they
go into the zone and um
you know no one's ever gone in no one's
ever come out or everyone who goes in
doesn't come out so it feels like that
and i'm feeling like it just needs a
little bit more um definition
and
clarity
in terms of like 3d assets that can be
dropped into
this little bit like maybe there's an
outpost i feel like there needs to be
like outposts or like a checkpoint thing
here or something but i like it man i'm
gonna give it the level up for sure
i think it deserves it
next up
ah interesting halo
halo render
all right so
i see what you're going for
but the biggest gripe
is the lighting the lighting just
doesn't do it for me it feels like um
yeah it just feels it feels like some
weird computer generated world you got
star wars you got halo um there's a lot
of things going on i don't know where i
am
um
you know but i really do like
these shapes here in the foreground i
think that's super cool that's what i
say i think i know what you're going for
i think that's awesome
i would just love some more of that and
you just you know got to keep working on
your lighting maybe
it looks like you're using an hdri to
light this but it's too bright it's
certainly too bright
and it needs a bit more shape
but i think i think your
your composition isn't half bad
it's not half bad
so keep going here
good work i hope you learned something
i hope you all learned something this
one let's take a look
how's everybody doing you guys doing all
right thumbs ups we got 400 people in
the chat we're reviewing art today and
we're going to pick three winners from
all from 130 submissions we're going to
pick three winners and it's going to be
tough
i'm gonna you guys are gonna win a
quadro
rtx 4000 an ssd
an nvidia
shield tv pro i'm gonna be sending you
guys some of my art prints as well like
it's gonna be a good time
so this one okay okay
yeah where am i what world is this um it
definitely has some like
stuzor vibes going from instagram um
i like the neon lighting i think it's
cool and i think the character in the
background is kind of cool i like that
you have an orbiting
[Music]
sky which isn't the first thing i
noticed
the the guy on the right this rock on
the right
it it's a little it's not confusing it's
just like a circle basically same for
this area it's just like a circle
so that's what i'm talking about when
it's like
you want to more clearly define your
silhouette if i were to squint my eyes
and just look at the silhouette
what can i learn from that you know so
you want to clearly define that visually
define
your world with a nice silhouette
and light it in such a way that it
describes it like this hand i kind of
lose in with the sky i'm like losing
that a little bit
um
it looks like some giant graveyard or
something you can maybe have a bit more
hands scattered about and
maybe light it i i like this like
king mountain dude i think that's cool
when you're strobing
[Music]
little lines here are cool
but you know you left your character and
um
the ground plane just feels
i think just more work could go into
this definitely if you don't know look
up stewsor
on instagram you'll get a lot of good
inspiration from there but yeah good
work
very very good work
moving on
all right
let's take a look
okay interesting interesting i like your
character i really do like these hanging
lights that is cool and you have a
little character tethered to them which
is a little hard to see i feel like it's
blends into the mountain it's the same
color as a mountain so that could
probably be a different color or have
some lights on it or something
your ground is you know
just like one thing that's what i'm
talking about like
maybe adding some more detail into your
ground and some
contrast some visual contrast in the
ground could help out a lot but i like
this like rustic like these real intense
pipes
and spikes sticking out of the ground i
think that's cool but i do think that
your silhouette is
broken up by
it's close you know it's close i think
you could probably shape these a little
bit more
and it looks like these don't have much
of a texture on them
and i don't quite know what is going on
or who this character is but it looks
cool it looks cool
um
you have a spaceship coming i don't know
if you need the spaceship
it's fine though but this is cool the
mountain opening up revealing this
glowing light from the inside i think
that's pretty sweet
i think this i think this one
we gotta be harsh here are we gonna
i think i'm gonna be harsh i think i'm
gonna move on yeah i think we're gonna
continue on good work though i think
this is this is awesome
um
you know i think you can probably maybe
work on your lighting a little bit more
it's a little flat
yeah
good work though good work moving on
moving on here we go next one
let's take a look
maybe i'm just getting harsher as i go
you know as i go through these
this one literally looks like my friend
casey
this is cool man this mermaid this
reminds me of uh
half-life 1 when you go to the alien
world a little bit
and i like these spinning lights and you
have the animated
the animated wires which is cool
this giant wire to the left i'm not
quite sure what that is
it's too smooth
need some surface imperfection
um and it looks like you're you
rendered at a really low sample rate
maybe just to get it into the 100
megabyte limit
but yeah no this is desk training vibes
you have like the highway going with
everything it's pretty sweet
um but i do feel that
there's a lot lacking in the texture
quality
um it could be a lot more
higher res you can have a lot more
contrast here
uh visual contrast different kinds of
material different kinds of ground plane
mixed in with this
but you got the fog you know certainly
got the fog going
and this this dude's just looking like a
regular dude like why is this dude here
that's a good question i want to know
the answer
i'll give it the level up
we'll get the level up on that
next one oh i mean i can just level this
one up
you get the level up
absolutely
this is great no this is really nice um
i love your character i love your
lighting i love your environment
um
the only thing i'm missing out on is
this mountain look at the mountain it's
really low res and i don't know what
this scribbly light is i don't know if
that's lava or
i don't know i don't know
um
it would have been nice to have some
like
you know some uh
some snow on that thing i think would
have been cool but man you put so much
work into your foreground and your mid
ground this looks really nice
it's just like that that background is
not complete and it doesn't
quite you know
it falls flat in that sense
but
everything else is amazing like your
fence your quarantine your dude like
this is awesome this is really really
cool i dig it
so you got the level up for sure
moving on
this one okay
so my first thing where am i i don't
know where i am
it's kind of scary looking
um you're going through a door and going
to another place i i get the idea i get
the idea i just think the execution
um
you could have spent more time on it or
maybe this was your best and this is all
you had and if if so congratulations
like seriously
um maybe you learned how to use blender
for this who knows
that's why i can't be too harsh on you
guys you know everyone's putting in good
work here
but yeah i think this one the lighting
needs to be a bit more defined um your
mountain in the background feels tiny
and pasted in really the biggest one for
me on this is lighting
second would be
composition
you have the symmetry thing going
this is off center i'd probably center
this thing a little bit i'd center this
this uh
this planet your sky is just one color
i'd get a sky going you know
and
more detail you want more detail in your
ground plane
um
and really like what are you going for
is this water you're going through
because if this is water with like the
grass on the side to some cliffs
like this is a cool idea
and i think if spent more if you had
more time and maybe a bit more
experience you could take this
to the next level
um
i love this glowing green pipe though
that's my favorite part about the whole
thing
so good work good work
oh visual you you know
you can't ha you can't hog the freaking
submission process and
and dane you two
both y'all i know you guys are
submitting just so uh
to make sure i got your submission i get
it
i'm just giving you a hard time all
right next one
same deal where are we i don't know
where we are the lighting on this one
is lacking um
i don't know what these little
macaroni things are i'm not quite sure
your color is
i wouldn't say all over the place you
know you have your pink and blue
with a little bit of green in there
that's not bad
um personally this is just a style thing
i'm not the biggest fan of like
super crazy colors alien world kind of
stuff
um like i need i need to feel grounded
and the only thing that grounds me in
this is the character but barely you
know it's definitely some alien
character um and then
that's about it you know that's the only
thing that i have to ground me it makes
me feel like i don't want to be here um
not in a bad way it's just some alien
landscape where i'm like i don't know
about this
but
there's a road
with clearly tire marks going here so
there must be some sort of truck
somewhere that's interesting
um
but yeah i think this one
if you're gonna do some alien sort of
world like this i would definitely look
up games that do this kind of stuff like
god i can't think of any right now i can
only think of spore that's the only
thing i could think of
um
but there's been some really good ones
you know in the recent uh last couple
years that have taken place on alien
worlds like this i'm trying to think of
they're like someone with a spaceship
and you
fly around and visit planets reference
that try and get that look
um
but i see what you're going with here
keep it up though all right keep it up
all right moving on
oh man this movie crushed me great with
the fireflies
yikes um
[Music]
i love this a lot of you guys
have done this like cartoony ghibli
style render render style i love it
um this one's cool man it's a breath of
fresh air i have a style change now i
love your sky your clouds are cool
they're moving
um you have fire with the
b25 bomber dropping some bombs
super jacked up
you have bamboo in the yards um you're
in an alleyway here i love it your
character's cool and you have
the side character going
i like this i like this i'm just gonna
get the level up for me it feels fresh
i think it's well composed
your colors are nice good good choice
with the color oh my god
level up for sure on this one
this is craziness look at this
look at the detail on this man oh my god
so cool
um
geez so much going on
wow
this is amazing
like everything everything in this holy
crap
i don't even know where to start
so
it's called lord of the rings
you got an orc over here i mean dude
yeah this is freaking awesome this is so
cool you have your tattered flag you
have your your water on the right your
atmosphere and smoke over here on the
right
there's atmosphere and smoke everywhere
and there's like stuff going up into the
sky like i don't know if that's like
dark souls kind of stuff
your background is full of like
simulations and explosions and oh my god
no this is nutty this is this is nutty
this gets the level up for sure
absolutely amazing
great work the only gripe it's hard to
tell
what the character is just kind of looks
like a glowing blob
and there's there's almost so much going
on that it's hard to fix my eye on like
one thing but this is awesome like you
really built out this world so well
great work i love your silhouette your
shape and your contrast or your
composition is really nice
yeah level up absolutely
this one okay so i've been playing a lot
of ghost of tsushima
and
i uh
i mean this one to me this one gets the
level up absolutely
i like it a lot
i love fog obviously you guys know me i
love my fog and my atmosphere but i
think you did a good job on the
character and i actually think the way
you color corrected it made it feel
filmic it feels like a movie it feels
real
um
you know i kind of did the same thing i
didn't have i wasn't the happiest with
my mountain so i covered it up with some
fog and you did a really good job here
now your water could be a little bit
have a bit more detail in it or maybe
maybe it could be it could be mud or
something but this is definitely a
flooded area the tory gates are flooded
the temple's flooded
and you know maybe the samurai built
some bridge to get to the mountain or
something
but dude this is freaking cool i love
the lights here in the background with
this
you have it got the level up for sure
oh my goodness
jesse
jesse juicy
i don't think your name is juicy
um
but man this is good
man this is really good this is this
might
this feels like a movie
yep
feels like a movie um
incredible
absolutely incredible
your lighting is ridiculous
your environment is ridiculous look at
how well
you placed all of these
trees
and
and bushes and grass and it's actually
blowing in the wind what program did you
use for this man
also i saw the front of your character
and it's hilarious it totally looks all
jacked up
but from the back it looks great this is
so good
wow it reminds me of
is kromfel his name
he has a really nice um
tutorial series on how to make
environments like this and it's just
absolutely oh no caller called her more
called her more that's his name i think
this is great man this is just so good
you get the level up for sure we can
dive into that later
but
that is amazing
next up this one totally reminds me of
the original dark souls
um
the part when you you know like
basically go into hell
and you have to open up all those gates
and stuff and then you fight that giant
dude in the back
it's this is exactly what it reminds me
of
and you just got your average joe
walking through here like no big deal
this is
super creepy um i love this the oh dude
the only thing look at this top left
this fire is huge you need to slow that
fire down bigger things move slower so
slow that fire down
um it'll make it feel larger um
now this is good man
good job on the sky
good job on this like freaking demon up
here and the chair
you guys are these chairs you know
these center-framed large chair people
i love it
your lighthouse
is terrifying
it's so terrifying this really gives me
a sense i can feel the environment here
this is so good man really good work i'm
gonna give this the level up for sure
all right
next up so um
i forget this gentleman's name
[Music]
but he hit me up and he said he only had
he had a render problem and could only
render 30 33 frames so apologies
and this is what you had man um not bad
not bad at all you know you get your
glass uh
your frozen lake on the right your
character going through
um
the snow on his head going towards the
mountain
not bad at all you got some trees going
here
uh your lighting is good i think this is
good yeah this is good nice
nice hdri background back there
um
now what i would do to add to this man
like maybe i would tweak the exposure a
little bit lower the exposure give it a
vignette color correct it a little bit
um
give the sun maybe a lens flare
but i like how this falls off into foggy
kind of a foggy background i think
that's really good did a good job with
that
maybe you can use a little bit more um
variety in your plant choice
here in the snow
um
but this isn't bad this is not bad at
all like it almost looks like a bunch of
trees here and then it comes down to a
clearing on the right
what i mean it almost looks like that it
is that i'm just describing the image
uh that's my review it's just describing
the image
what i'd do to make this better
maybe some fog on top of the mountain i
don't know
maybe work on your visual
uh composition just a little bit
uh switch out the character for sure but
i think this is good man certainly good
i'm sad it's not the full
88 frames
but i think you did a really good job
you know i think this if this was 88
frames i'd give it the level up
um and i'm hoping that you can
maybe render the rest of that because
i'd love to include it in the montage
video i think it'd be cool
alright this one we saw
let's take a look at this one
so here's one where i don't quite know
where this is i feel
like
this is a scary place
definitely a scary place um
the lighting i think is a little tough i
don't know where this blue
i guess are these lights are these all
lights going down here
i guess so
the ground i don't know what that is i'm
not quite sure what that ground is and i
don't know why
um like a civilization would build out
all of these like watch towers
but i don't know what they're watching
what are they watching and you have like
a lighthouse thing up here which looks
cool
i think the foreground just needs a bit
more story a bit more
clarity
as to what's going on
and your lighting looks like it's being
lit from the side over here some side
light action
you get some fog some like misty smoke
that's cool not bad
but yeah i'm missing where am i
what um what's going on
those are the things that i that i
am feeling and also
i'm lacking the
the foreground element you know the
story in the foreground
i feel like maybe with
i don't know with some stuff to look
over with some stuff to watch these are
definitely watch towers it looks like
watch towers to me maybe their homes but
why are the homes
built up on stilts like that
is it a flooded area i mean there's
water down here so maybe that's why
but maybe some bridges between the homes
could be cool
but yeah this one just barely just
barely
missed out on the level up just barely i
think
defining those things could help us out
a lot
and i think tweaking your lighting a
little bit more could help too what's
your reference for the lighting on this
finding that reference i think could
help out a lot
all right moving on
oh this one
is this one is nice
so how are you guys doing are you guys
hanging in there give me some thumbs ups
if you're still hanging in there with me
i really hope you guys are are learning
something
with this critique um we still have 450
people up in here so that's really sweet
i appreciate you guys for for hanging in
there and sticking around i'm glad that
you know everyone's so interested in
figuring out everyone's art and seeing
everyone's art so that's really cool
awesome awesome
so this one's awesome look at this
i think the render quality is amazing
oh
oh you'll get your turn ivan
you will get your turn
yeah render quality is sick on this one
man it's super cool
you know couldn't change out the
character or didn't have time to change
with the character you see from the
chrome kind of vibe i dig it
chrome was the way to go on this though
because
it clearly stands out
um from the environment around this
person you're using the mega scans
mushrooms recognize those some mega
scans ferns and you've got some nice
movement in there too which is good
is that rd textures
on the rocks maybe it looks like it
maybe it's mega scans hard to tell but
those columns are really cool
um i dig your
these arches in the fog you got going
and you have like a nice lens flare here
too i think that's really nice
i'm just missing uh the mountain the
mountain disappears for me
but i love the way this sun peeks out
over that i think this is great i'm
gonna give the level up
just missing the mountain that's the
only thing
all right ivan
it's your time to shine
i think this is
amazing
all right it's got sound but i gotta
mute the sound hold on
how do i how do i mute the sound
if okay never mind i'll just do
what any normal person would do
all right there we go
you got some bruce willis looking dude
walking towards the american dream is
that a restaurant
not quite sure
oh man you got parallel dimensions
written on the side of this van that's
super cool like that easter egg you said
there's a few easter eggs i see a p and
y um
license plate that's super cool
and then this says
accessories
store
i'm not quite sure and then that says no
no value or no something
i wonder if i got all of
the easter eggs i know you said there's
a lot in here so that's cool you got
birds going i think the birds are moving
too slow birds are definitely moving too
slow
um
[Music]
but man you nailed the raindrops hitting
the ground here i think that's great you
got some paper flying on the ground
that's cool i love the city in the back
it feels like a grand theft auto just
outside of the city
kind of a thing
oh this dude has a gun
shot this guy
and is walking towards this place to
shoot those people
oh
man that's all jacked up great work with
the um lightning
i think you did a solid job with the
lightning up here
um
and your composition is great i really
like it man this feels complete you put
in all the work and you completed this
render you get the level up yeah of
course
oh
shoot this one
is
incredible
this one is so good look at those birds
so ivan remember talking about the birds
moving fast this is these are birds
moving a little faster i think this
feels about right
look at this
absolutely incredible look at those
birds back there by the handle of the
sword
it really the birds really give it scale
and you got the
the clouds coming over this thing oh my
god it looks so good
this is a complete render
absolutely incredible
you have your fog some nice
uh
foreground fog here so good your
lighting is incredible you filled out
the foreground with
different kinds of plants and bushes
really well done
i love your your colors here this
is that a gate he's walking towards this
giant gate definitely got some dark
souls or um
hyper light drifter kind of vibes
um i don't know what this thing is
that's the only thing like
oh it's going off in the background too
that is so cool
yeah it's really well done this is
this is a 10 out of 10 like
amazing amazing piece of art
absolutely yeah this gets the level up
for sure man
that is so good that is so good
oh this is cool
i like this so this is
i think the second person who's played
with scale
but you have this character walking
towards a window um
i love this
it's just like an art station it's all
maxed out you have a pencil rolling
that's so subtle i love it
um
save save render and save yes absolutely
is that cinema 4d or blender open on
your computer it looks like a laptop
with a parallel dimensions project file
i love it
this is awesome
man this is super cool this definitely
gets the level up i love your render
quality i think everything looks really
nice
i'm just seeing a little bit of like
noisy stuff here i don't know if you can
use a denoiser or something or just more
samples but
that you know you can take care of that
no problem this is amazing i love it the
only thing that bugs me about this one
is the character
because i'm not quite sure what the
character is i think now i'm looking at
it closer is
it's a it's a drawn character it's
sketched with the pencil
but you know what i think would be
better
is
those like wooden mannequins that you
use for art to like position
um for uh like perspective and stuff
when you're drawing characters it's kind
of like this guy back here but it's like
the wooden version
of it with like the wooden joints i
think that would be more fitting for the
scene because i'm just not quite sure
what this guy is i didn't really know
what he was at first
um and you even have the uh the tablet
pen
in the back dude that's super cool i
love this
yeah level up
all right here's one here's um
let's see
okay so with this one
this is another question of i don't know
where i am
um
and it's hard to tell
like what's going on to the right is
that buildings and then to the left is
that like future buildings
or something um
you got that's a sweet space cloak i
think that's pretty cool
um and then yeah you definitely got some
space stuff going on i think for me the
colors on this one is just like too
vibrant it's too much too intense
um and your lighting i think could just
be worked
a little bit it definitely gives me the
feeling of like scary like
other worldly fantastical kind of
feelings that
it's like it's a foreign world that
makes me
uncomfortable
which is good
you know you get a feeling out of
somebody that's okay that's what you
that's what you want you want to get a
feeling out of someone with a render
with any art
but i think it's just a matter of like i
don't know where i am
i don't
i'm confused as to what these buildings
are or who this is
um
it looks like the plants down here are
too small and you need that
uh
you need a wide variety of different
types of plants to make it not look like
it's just like the ones plant scattered
all over
i don't know what this thing is it's
floating in the sky i'm not sure
um i think this fog over here could work
on the fog yeah
and then some space dome or something
yeah i think with this again find your
reference with these ones
there's been a few like this you really
want to find a reference that you want
to go for so i think that would help you
on your next piece
and it will clearly define like what
you're going for
um and the more you do it maybe you can
start working without reference but i
always work with reference always always
so yeah work with reference next time
try and find a look or a lighting style
that you want to go for
um because it just feels a little all
over the place right now that's the only
thing
all right next one next one
[Music]
this is one of our
one of our own here this is so you know
this is all this is all of
all you guys are part of this whole
thing but this is sodamonte
i love it dude the ghibli render
your character's animated on twos which
means ev um basically every other frame
the character moves so you get that like
uh you know that spider-man
into the spider-verse kind of feel with
your character it feels like an anime
uh you have your flowing grass i love
but here's here's the thing soto um
i want that grass to be a little smaller
i feel like it's too tall it's blocking
too much of your character and i feel
like it needs more
again contrast in the plants i think you
need a couple more pieces of grass maybe
little patches maybe some darker patches
um i mean obviously you have your
reference you know it's house moving
castle
you know those
rolling plains that kind of stuff
um so i think you could go for a little
bit more contrast in your hills and
whatnot
your sky is incredible
totally looks like the sky from the
scene and spirited away when they're on
the train and they go by the house looks
like that i love i love your scene i
think the uh
the giant like air
uh turbines are super cool
and you even got a little waterfall
animation going which is awesome and i
know you're in blender
um so it's really really cool to see
that but yeah i want to see more of your
character man but dude this definitely
gets to level up i think it's awesome i
love how you go for a different style
so
shout outs
would it be awkward if i'm like nah dude
you don't get the level up maybe
maybe a little bit
alright this one
so
i don't know where i am
i don't know these what the structure is
surrounding the image
um
and the character i don't know who the
character is or what they're going for
um
yeah this one just has a lot of i have a
lot of questions with this one like
where where is this what is this
um these structures i'm not quite sure
what they are um
[Music]
i like your foreground element you know
you have the trees and the sticks
hanging in here i think that's cool it
breaks it up but i don't know what this
like cloudy patch is up here
stuck to the foreground i'm not sure
what that is
um
so i think
it's a little i wouldn't say all over
the place i think it just needs to be
kind of honed in a little bit more and
again
go for reference i'm wondering that you
know renders that
make me feel
uh like i want to know where we're at i
wonder if you guys used any reference
definitely use your reference that's
going to help out a whole lot
the texture on this
architecture here there isn't really any
so it's definitely lacking in that sense
um but hey you got some good tree models
in here
um and you switched out your character
costumes that's good
your ground plane i think is a little
too large i think they can be scaled
down
so reference really all this comes down
to is you guys using reference and
following your reference
please please please use reference
in the future
um
but yeah good work good work i hope
we're all learning something on this i
really do
okay this one this is definitely some
desk training vibes here
or what's that movie uh
the
um
isle of dogs
yeah it kind of reminds me of that a
little bit this one's cool man you got
the fog
going and there's a really cool like
little cave system up here
that's fun i like that
really interesting character you get the
radar on the back i like it
very barren kind of landscape
now compositionally i think your
energy pillars
can be scooted in a little bit
because we kind of lose them by the end
of the render we're losing them off the
frame i i want to see them scrunched in
just a little bit maybe here and here
like maybe where this mountain is i
could
i could feel that and also the ground i
feel like again is a little too big
those cracks
i feel like it'd be a little bit smaller
and i think you can have a bit of visual
definition a bit more visual definition
in your in your textures on the ground
too you want to break it up a little bit
but i love i love your fog and your
atmosphere here yeah i think you did a
really good job with that you nailed
that look um it feels a little rest to
me i think it's just the way you
rendered it is the only way you can get
it in definitely do a high-res version
of this man you deserve it i think it's
awesome
um and i love i love this like cloak
thing that you added to the character i
think it's great and i love your colors
too so it gets the level up for me
all right anthony
get some star wars vibes
good render quality i like your render
quality and i like your character
um
your environment is nice too this
inverted pyramid is awesome
really dig this thing i'm not sure what
this is i don't know if it's a spaceship
or what
but
these inverted pyramids are really cool
and these little huts back here are cool
i feel like this inverted pyramid is
just
taking or not inverted pyramid i'm sorry
the this like
i'm going to call it a spaceship
it feels like it's like a black void
kind of taking me out i i feel like i'd
remove this
and i'd add more of this kind of stuff
the pyramids and the huts i love these
things they're super cool
and you have some pillars here i feel
like maybe the pillars
could be
guiding his walk in his path
up to the mountain
i also think you could use
um
where the sand meets the mountain i feel
like you can actually have a more of a
transition between the sand and the
mountain versus just this line
and the mountain feels small to me it
feels very very close
so i don't know if there's some things
you could do like maybe add some tiny
birds up there to make it feel smaller
or maybe it's just the way you texture
it textured the mountain which it's
tough the mountain was tough for me too
so maybe maybe you just needed a bit
more finer detail up there to spend a
bit more time on the mountain but i love
your your um your like haze layer i
think that's nice your sun over here
like this this blast of white with um
this like yellow fall off on this
pyramid it it does pull my eye up there
but it's so far over there you know i i
want to keep it central
um
[Music]
maybe if this was kind of
i like the your long shadow is really
nice
this is really good it's a good render
it's going to get the level up for me
for sure
so we'll move you up on the next track
oh my god we are not even we're about
halfway done i gotta i gotta keep moving
this one is amazing
that that is dude yeah this one's
freaking cool
i'm honestly blown away by this one
this
is incredible
i love the style so much there's a guy
on instagram i forget his name but he
does stuff like this
yeah this is this is next level here um
i love how your smoke is animated on the
twos
i wish your character was on the twos as
well like i really
i just love that look i love that look
so much
this is incredible
the lightning up here dude yeah you get
the level up
absolutely
oh man
danny
this is sweet
this is another example of playing with
scale
oh so cool
and very disgusting very creepy because
these ants are crawling into this hole
with a light in it and there's a giant
shoe here with like rocks stuck in the
soles the detail on that's incredible
oh man
i love your character you switch out the
character really nice
and the foreground like all these sticks
and everything i love this play with
scale i think it's great
the shader on your ants is great look at
the you can see them glowing from the
inside that is really well done
very very cool
this one's incredible this one
definitely gets the level up for me
moving on so this came in two i think
this was we'll start with this one
so this one
is um
another example of figuring out where we
are where are we and what's going on
um
you know
like it feels kind of like you're in a
space station and you're entering a
different world but it just needs more
work like your ground plane is literally
invisible here on the ground here
um
[Music]
and your mountain has just like one lava
texture it'd be nice to see the ground
actually be some lava too
um
but yeah the missing ground plane and
it's like
your entire ground plane is gone it's
just your hdri so that's kind of
bleeding through so
definitely want to add a ground
on the next round
um
and then yeah i'm missing the scale this
feels very tiny to me your
transformation is cool though that's my
favorite part of the whole thing is the
transformation so that's awesome
all right
next up
so this one feels very dark
it looks like it's being lit from behind
the camera a little bit is that a lego
is that a freaking lego dude back here
what on earth
why that's really funny um
it's not bad yeah it's not bad you have
a grass going here
it looks like the wind kicks up at one
point and then the mantis raises up you
got some fog right here in the
foreground
mantis is coming up this guy this one's
creepy um it's certainly creepy
you get that scale definitely that that
like perspective
going um
it just feels i think your lighting is
the biggest issue here for me on this um
it's a little too dark it's just too
dark
and it'd be cool if the mantis was
hidden
and then it and then it raised up and it
revealed itself i think that'd be cool
your character itself
i don't know what that thing on his back
is saw blade maybe
but yeah this this isn't bad i think you
could just work on your lighting
um and
maybe
scoot this grass over on the right scoot
it over a little bit more to the right
so you have this clear symmetrical
kind of path guiding right to the
mountain it's a little off center it's
not the worst i think that's more of a
stylistic choice
it's just the lighting to me i think is
the biggest issue
all right another another example of of
where are we what is this place it's an
alien world
and it's scary i don't want to be here
this is terrifying
um
you have a fedora man walking towards
this green
thing i like how you hollowed out the
mountain that's nice actually i think
that's cool
but
i feel like this one's just lacking in
in detail and
um
clarity of like where we are what this
is where we're going if you're going for
some like avengers end game
kind of feeling um
[Music]
maybe use that as the reference
and pull it up and really try and get it
there i think you're missing some fog
some atmosphere it feels miniature to me
your scale i think it needs atmosphere
in order to make this feel a little bit
smaller and your crystals um
are
you know they just kind of stop right
here
so i think you need to maybe
again use more reference to guide um
your your creative choices here and fill
out this world so an alien planet even
though it's an alien planet it doesn't
mean all rules of nature
are out the window you should probably
follow
some rules of nature
in fact i think it's probably 80 percent
rules of nature there's a 80 20 rule
basically it's a rule that says 80
percent should be
something that's familiar and 20 percent
should be something new
this is too much in the 20 percent
this is like
10 familiar 90
foreign so i think you need to really
rope it back even though it's an alien
planet and make it feel um
more familiar that's what i'm that's
what i'm lacking the lighting yeah it's
tough with the lighting and when i say
familiarity i mean like everything with
the lighting with the composition
um
even with the character i'm not quite
sure who it is
this one wow there's a lot going on on
this one
holy crap
it's really cool but my eye is like all
over the place i don't know where to
look
there's so much going on
that'd be the only like
downside to this one is just
your composition there's too much going
on for me to try and focus on one or two
things
i'm trying to read the text
you know there isn't any contrast
in terms of your composition
you know the whole thing feels heavy
i need parts that are heavy parts that
are light
and this is all personal this is all
personal um just into my style you know
this this could certainly work at a
certain in a certain place
but i think what would really help this
is just defining your focal point and
focusing your your value and your
contrast and your light there and having
everything else kind of like fall off
onto the sides maybe it's a color thing
maybe you do it with colors everything's
one unique or one uniform color right
now
maybe if you made the central point warm
and everything outside of it
cool
that could actually help focus your
energy on or focus your
your your eye
on one point
so you can use color
you can use composition
you can use contrast and you can use um
what else
yeah composition basically is
how you choose to put things
and shape things in your image you can
use that to draw the eye you can use
color to draw the eye color contrast you
can use a light contrast so value to
draw the eye as well it's just too over
it's too all over the place for me
but it's well done i think it's cool i
think it's super cool
you know what that one that one i'll get
the level up on that one okay
i got
you mmm interesting okay
this is a complete piece
i like it
um
you got the birds going
very nice
your lighting is not that bad
it's the end of the day
i think your mountain is really cool
good job on the mountain
um and you have a little radar dish up
top it's cool you got some birds
animated on the left on the wire it's
really nice
um
what's missing from this what's missing
from this
your atmosphere is good your light from
the city is good
i think what's missing you could
probably go more detailed on the road
more detail on the mud on the right
i think you can use a bit more contrast
when i say contrast um you can use
a bit more variation in your
your shrubs
and then i think you could probably i
think it's the sky for me that's getting
me it's like
maybe the horizon could be more of like
a daytime and then as you get up into
here it's a storm
you know just kind of stormy all around
but it's not necessarily bad you know i
think i think this is good and this gets
the level up for me
we did this one
oh
this one okay this one gets a level up
yeah
let's jump in and see why
i'm a huge samurai fan i love it
um this is freaking cool
so this is an example of a piece of art
that's busy there's a lot going on
but it has
um
it's uniform and it has it has like uh
what's the word i'm looking for
um it has a direction it has a direction
all of the elements in the scene
is are guiding my eye to the center
towards the mountain
what i mean by um light value and light
contrast to guide the eye it's you're
seeing it here it's very dark on very
bright
and that's guiding my eye right here
it's the brightest and the darkest point
of the image
these torches are coming down to a
vanishing point
up to the central point here towards
this temple
and then you have this nice um these
temples these floating temples
guiding your eye it's the cemetery
guiding right here and then you have
your cherry blossom trees
that are on the left and right as well
so you're definitely going for that
symmetry i like this one a lot um you
have particles in the air
that give it depth and you have these
clouds back into the background which
also give a depth the only thing i think
can make this better
is
fog
slash atmosphere between your temple and
your mountain
because i'm losing this temple
right
so i want to be able to see the shape of
this temple
against the mountain and i'm not
because they're the same color basically
so what i need is some sort of fog card
or atmosphere behind the temple and in
front of the mountain to make it pop out
a little bit more but i love this i
think your colors
are just wild enough to be crazy and
fantastical but not wild enough so that
it's like where the heck am i this feels
really cool i like this a lot this gets
the level up definitely
all right
so this one
is that rayquaza
from pokemon
okay this one
again kind of all over the place a
little all over the place um
it's just a lot it's a lot
i don't know what to focus my eye on
and i don't have anything to ground
myself on it's it's you know the 80 20
rule you want 80 familiar 20 foreign or
new you could say 80 80 is something i'm
used to and 20 is something new it's a
new idea this is like
new and foreign 10 percent
familiar like the only thing that's
familiar to me is this guy moving that's
it
um
your sky is a little crazy it's just
kind of like all over the place it's
like really intense
so
again my advice on these ones is to find
reference
what is your reference what are you
going for
and and work towards that find a good
reference and really build towards it
yeah that'd be my advice for that one
but good work i hope you learned
something that's the whole point guys i
hope you learned something you got some
you know this is cool if this is like
your first year in blender or whatever
like you're doing some cool stuff you
know you got some light bouncing off the
mountain some glowy stuff you got some
characters that are animated
literally you're animating characters
you're animating these little things
you've got a character in the scene like
you're doing good stuff if this is
you know like year one or year two and
blender like keep it up
so we've seen that one
oh i like this one this one's cool
i like your colors
and of course i love the whole japanese
vibe
um i still gotta beat ghost to tsushima
i'm really close
yeah this is cool i like it you got your
character going here with the cherry
blossom the animated cherry blossoms
which are animated kind of the same like
they're kind of breathing they're like
one two one two and you can see the
repetition in it good work on the birds
you got the birds going your mountain
looks a little low res but i love your
temple up there
your ground plane is the biggest thing
that's throwing me right now it's just
it's just glass which i get i get you it
is water
but
it feels
like it's just missing detail feels like
i'm missing detail
i know there's reference for this
there's some salt flats that flood over
just a little bit in like utah and stuff
so you can definitely reference that
um
maybe it's your lighting
you might be able to tweak the lighting
to make it feel a bit more realistic
um but it has that like video gaming
kind of render feeling to it but i love
your particles in the air i think it's
really nice
maybe next time start your particles
start emitting your particles um on
frame negative 100 so that they're they
start in the scene
you know unless you wanted it this way
but you definitely have two win two
crosswinds blowing in like this which is
interesting
very interesting
i think it's cool though
i think it's cool good work
next up
we got this freaking like
dark metal
album cover
swedish metal album cover band sweet
um yeah man good work you got your fog
you got your atmosphere you got your
composition going which is super cool
again this is kind of like stews or
feelings if you guys know instagram got
a guy on instagram by stuzor kind of get
those feelings you got the giant statues
i love your lighting i love your clouds
you got the birds in there you got doing
some cool stuff with the mountain back
here i think that's cool you have some
trees going i love your composition i
love your lighting it's getting the
level up
oh this one is cool
ah very very cool i love this this is
unique this is
very different i like it so first off
great render quality
um
nice composition
cool lighting love your lighting
and the idea that's the next level you
in the next level you have an idea with
this like
you're doing something different you
know people have ideas but you're doing
something different
um you're combining these worlds it is
the parallel dimension
i love it it's really cool
you got your floating leaves in the
foreground your particles and whatnot
really good work on the detail with your
ground plane
i'm always like that's that's the first
thing is like the ground plane i'm
seeing that it's the closest so it's got
to be the highest detail
good work on this man
i really love it you get the level up
for sure
we've seen this one
ooh mdk
what's up all right
so i've never seen the movie cars
but i need to
your render quality amazing always good
oh my god you literally mosaiced out
you mosaiced out the license plate
but you forgot on this frame right here
and it says peter
and nico
and sam and ren and clint
that's some next level
dude that's the next level that is cool
wow
that's awesome dude
that's super fun i love it
um is this supposed to be like the trial
where nico's on trial
i don't know but your render quality is
really nice your lighting is nice your
atmosphere and your fog is really nice
um your framing is good it's coming up
to this stop sign
i love it yeah you have your volumetric
fog in there you get the level up
of course your renders are always really
nice man
that's hilarious
this one feels like
oh
hold on
you remember the moment
and at the end of the matrix when neo
realized he was the one
that's what i feel like this one is
and when you like starts when he starts
seeing and code and everything
like that's the vibe i get from this
it's really cool um you have the
floating rocks and the particles like
the swirling mountain
i think it's amazing
um i'm just
i'm missing out a little bit on the
character again it's like
it's glowy and it's just kind of this
glowy blob i'm not really getting a
character from that um but your
landscape is incredible i really like
your landscape it feels really intense
like you've traveled all your life to
come to this point
and you have the swirling particle
effect around the mountain which is
really cool this one gets the level up
for me
all right star wars vibes
i love it
very cool
now it looks like a miniature because
of your depth of field
um i really dig
the
these big sand crawlers i think those
are cool and your building in the back
is awesome
your character is great too
this has a really good feeling to it uh
your hdri and your lighting i really dig
you're using your lighting here this is
cool you have streaks of sunlight and
shade sunlight and shade and it helps
the character stand out so i really like
that you're side lighting your character
your render quality is really nice this
gets the level up for me
so we're making it to the next level
all right this next one is world war one
a lot of work went into this one didn't
it
wow
so i know where i know where we're at
this is some world war one stuff right
here um
it's a it's a battle for the battle of
all battles going on right now the
forest is on fire the mountain's on fire
everyone's going crazy we're running
through no man's land
um
really well done yeah this is really
well done i like
what you're going for i think your
composition is good
i can tell what's going on i know what's
going on i know who your characters are
i know where we're at i know where time
period we're at so that's good
um
[Music]
i think your your models are a little
low poly i think you could have used
maybe a little depth of field to hide
the foreground just a little bit
you could use motion blur motion blur is
going to help you out a lot with these
guys falling down
um
certainly
and i think if you scale down the
texture for your lights in the mountain
it's going to make the mountain feel a
little bit smaller or um it's going to
come out and feel bigger so if you take
these little like flickering lights
which is cool and you maybe just make
them a bit more clear and smaller it's
going to make the mountain feel bigger
um
looks like the mountain is being lit by
the fire to the left and right
good work on the sky i think you got the
sky down really nice nice um space hdri
this one gets the level up i think it's
good i think it's really good
whoa
that's intense so did this dude just
cast a spell or did
was his spell
incomplete
because like the lasers coming into the
middle to the middle of the the
character feels like a spell is being
cast he's not a robe
but i mean really good job on your
your simulation for the mountain
explosion like that's incredible it's
coming from this little spot up here
um it looks like you use world builder
maybe for
um to texture the mountain and
everything
it looks really good your mountain looks
super solid
um and falling off in the background
looks really nice too custom sim and
everything
good work with reflection on the lake in
the foreground
your foreground foreground i feel like
needs work because i don't know what
that is is it sand is it concrete is it
rock i don't know
but i think it's good enough to get the
level up
so you made it to the next level we've
seen this one
oh man
another ghibli render y'all in ghibli i
love it
so this
one
animated on the twos as well so it looks
like that stop motion anime effect
um
i love it
beautiful
shout outs to how's moving castle if you
guys don't know i'm a big ghibli fan and
i actually got myself a little
little castle here
a little house moving castle i got this
one at the ghibli museum in japan
and it comes apart like it has a bunch
of different pieces and like
you know little
hidden little cubbies and stuff
all right anyway back to the render
i love it i love the feeling of this
my only gripe
is the foreground grass and it needs
some contrast that needs different kinds
of grass darker spots brighter spots
um and it needs to be flowing in the
wind it's very static i need that flowy
wind like sodamontes you had the flowing
wind
um and you have some clouds some
animated clouds i feel like your your
hdri background you can be moving that a
little bit too but this one gets the
level up i think it's cool
all right tristan
very nice good render quality nice
character
creepy lighting
reminds me of 1917 a little bit
um good work on the fire thing going out
here in the back i think that's really
cool
um
now this one definitely gets the level
up it certainly gets the level up you
have a animated flag going here what
would i do to make this better i think
it's the lighting i think i would
now there's a spotlight on this guy
maybe having a helicopter in the back
or or maybe having spotlights up
on the buildings on top of the buildings
pointing down on this guy i think could
be really cool like 28 weeks later when
the zombies came in and they had all the
guys on the roof
that could justify the spotlight i want
to know where the spotlight's coming
from
the fire i don't know what's on fire so
if he's walking towards it maybe it'd be
a good idea to have like a crashed plane
or something there scoot your bus over
so i can see what's going on a little
bit more so i'd work on composition and
just to find the lighting a little bit
more but you get the level up for sure
now when we did the um
when we were in the early stages of the
submission progress or process martine
submitted this image or this render and
nvidia actually tweeted it um tweeting
about the contest and everything super
cool amazing really good work on this i
think this is incredible
um you got this monk stepping towards
the mountain
really good idea i love your idea
the ground or the background itself just
feels a little static um
you know you just have the birds and the
character moving which is cool
but i'm it just feels like an image it
might as well be an image and i can see
that your clouds are moving a little bit
but i feel like they're not moving
enough
and i'd love to see a bit more of
something down here on the ground
because it's like mostly clouds which is
cool it's definitely the vibe you're
going for
um but i mean this definitely gets the
level up for me i think it's really nice
um your crows
i wonder i feel like if your crow's a
part of the lighting
it's hard to tell
or maybe it's just the way they're
animated like they're circling around
the sky
and like it doesn't feel natural like a
bird can't fly in that perfect of a
circle i think it needs to be like like
hovering or something
but anyway you get the level up that's
really nice
i mean this is awesome big fan of legend
of zelda
love the idea good times
i love the style i got my sucker for
this kind of style
i think this is really cool very unique
i love your clouds yeah really nice
cloud over here
got a little spiral going on here
what would i do to make this better
um
shrink the shield probably so i can see
link more i want to see his arms
that'd be my thing
but good work you see what i mean by
contrast and variation in the
ground you did that with your plants and
everything i think that's really nice
and maybe there's a way to
to break up this line from grass to
mountain you can probably break that up
in a different way so you know the
mountain would have some grass going up
to the rock it wouldn't just be a rock
you know
but you get to level up
i think it's good
randy
what you got for us randy
so a lot of good detail work here on the
buildings
there's a lot going on um yeah the foggy
mountain in the background
spotlight on the police car so i'm
missing your character i cannot see your
character that's the thing
i want to see that character
um
[Music]
you know put a light on them or
something
something if you're going for a
silhouette then shine a light on this
truck in the background so i can see the
silhouette of your character's head
you know
um
but i like this empty city i think it
feels really creepy i think your your
street though i think it needs a bit
higher res texture going on here it
needs some some lines
um
and just a bit more detail probably just
i think it needs a bit more detail like
in these lights up here i've never seen
these kind of lights so then that's when
i'd go for reference
where have you seen street lights like
this
um if you have
then that's great i just think they're
lacking in their texture they need some
surface imperfections same for the
street lamp there's just a little low
res
but the main thing for me is the
character
you get the level up though because
it it has a little you got you got
something going on there i think you
have something going on so you get the
level up you go to the next level
gabriel
now you can only submit once you can
only win once
i'm sorry you can submit multiple times
but you can only win for one this is
another one you also did this one here
but this
looks to me like a
walking
turd man
but i see i think this is um among us
i think it's among us yeah this is a
creepy this is creepy
the the
the environment oh is that someone
getting blown out up here
it is
the environment feels very foreign it's
too foreign to me
definitely a crashed ship going on here
crash ship vibes i get it
but it feels a little empty you know i
like your original your your link render
a little bit better
but good work you got sparks going here
some tubes animating all around
but your character i don't know what
this character is i i didn't know at
first that it was among us
so
i need a bit more definition and clarity
on
what is going on here
so this one
has a little bit more i'd say this is
more like
70 percent foreign
60 foreign
what's familiar to me is the character
um this generator
the buildings
it's all war torn and destroyed
but i think it's the lighting that's
getting me the most on this one
it's a little all over the place i'm
getting a lot of different kind of
light shades and casts i'd stick with
i'd keep it a little bit more simple um
[Music]
it might be your sky i think you might
need a different hdri
because it looks like just one color
right now
um
and your shader on the mountain
you know i need a little bit more it
looks like just a dirt pile it looks
like a small dirt pile
but i like what you're going for here i
feel like you just needed to keep
working on it keep uh embellishing this
this art i don't know if this is blood
running down the middle or what
um
it needs atmosphere up here you need a
bit of atmosphere i think you could just
tweak your lighting your composition is
not bad
it's certainly symmetrical you have a
large object here a large object here
center frame so your composition isn't
the worst um i think it just needs help
with the lighting
and your color choice
but good work
good work i hope we're all learning
stuff
so same deal here
where are we i mean we're on a road
we're on a road with some cars on it
that are floating why are the cars
floating is the character pushing the
cars away
is it like akira are we headed towards a
city in the background i mean there's no
city
you're missing your texture here on the
left and right of the ground we're
missing that and
your
column
here you need to like bevel definitely
got to bevel your edges catch the light
there i think it just needs a bit more
detail
on your asset
you got some fog going off into the
background
i don't know why the mountain has this
orange cast on it but at least it has
something it does draw my eye but the
the cars are honestly distracting i
think they're moving too fast you can
probably slow them down
and i think you can have your character
doing that you can you can insinuate
your character is doing that maybe by
having like a force field coming out
you can't move their hands obviously
because we were locked to a certain
animation
but i think you could have like
force field maybe coming out of the
character something or a shock wave
blowing out
to show that the characters are doing
this and it looks like
you're using like a scan line renderer
or something
um
[Music]
because it doesn't look like the cars
are being lit by the environment around
it
but they're definitely being reflected
down here
but yeah again what's your reference
check out akira the opening scene of
akira that might be a good reference for
you
we've seen this one
all right
star wars
okay so you're on a snowy island oh my
god that planet is going insane
and those
the
the ships are like whoa
flying over the top
okay this one um
there's a lot going on there's there's
too much going on there's like these
ships are warping in you got these ships
flying by you got these ships zooming
behind the mountain like it's too much
it's too much i like your environment
though it's dark and foggy and snowy and
maybe it's ash i don't know i'd lean
into that you know maybe worry less
about the ships and more on really
building out the detail of your
environment this um
explosion back here
i think it's a little distracting
it's the brightest part of the image so
my my mind only sees that part i think
your overall image is a little too dark
i don't know why this planet is spinning
like crazy
um
cool asset you hear you have on the left
i almost want to see more of that i
think you can push it back more
and i want to just i want you to
consider
your horizon in the silhouette that
makes up your horizon how does how does
your foreground break up
in and and fall off into your background
if you're squinting your eyes and if or
if you were to just color your
foreground silhouette black could you
tell what's going on i think it's just a
little too much going on
um with this one
um i think you can brighten up the image
overall a little bit more
in the center especially
um it's just too dark
but yeah good work you know
um definitely a lot of a lot of good
things going on here i think you do have
a lot of good things going on with this
one
and we're moving on
to this next one
all right i got an interesting lighting
shift
and it loops
good work you got the loop
very cool
um
so this is some sort of alien planet i
guess as well i don't know where we are
um it's interesting certainly
interesting
reference wise
reference wise killzone 3
or maybe it's kill zone four look at the
concept art for kill zone three and kill
zone four
and see if you can't work that in
maybe next time into into your
your reference
because it looks like you had some sort
of reference
because it's not completely all over the
place
it does feel like a lot there's a lot
going on
um and i think it's cool how your
mountain and your colors line up with
the colors of your character
i just feel like it's missing something
maybe it's just the architecture
you know it's like just the same
architecture going off into the
background and i don't know if is that a
ship in the back or what i'm just a
little confused it's all as to what you
know where we are what's going on
so again try and find reference
and match your reference definitely
match your reference also time spend a
lot you gotta spend a lot of time to
make this stuff look and feel complete
it's tough
so there's two tron ones there's this
one
and there's this one i'm gonna go with
this one
because
actually here i'll get back to it so
there's an old school tron one
but i like the new one better
so let me review these two and we'll do
the we'll do the new one now this one
okay
there's something about this one
though it is
foreign to me i don't know where we are
or what this is
it feels cool
your graphical sense and your graphical
style
is really good
so
good work really good work
i like this like
it's simple enough
that i know
like it feels good to me it just feels
good your colors are sick i love your
colors and i love how they're reflected
off the ground
like this definitely feels like a music
video
it has a hand-drawn feel to it which i
really enjoy
and of all of the abstract otherworldly
ones this one has got to be my favorite
so i'm gonna i'm gonna give this one the
uh the level up
it's been a minute since we leveled
something up
so here's the tron one that i think is
better
so you got the light cycles going by
character walking forward
so it's not bad you know good render
quality
i'd like to see the focus
you know the depth of field is a little
too shallow i'd like to see it more
focused on the mountain
i feel like you could brighten up the
center part of your image brighten up
your mountain
and maybe have that beam of light coming
from
this point
here to really brighten up like this
part this side of the mountain
um
[Music]
i feel like you can maybe push the light
cycles back towards the mountain a
little bit more too
give it more of a vignette darken this
darken the edges and brighten up the
center point
i think that's the only thing that's
lacking from this but i like it i'll
give it the
the the the level up
are we getting into duplicates which is
good because we are nearing the end
and then
we go to the next level which will be
easier because then we have seen
everything you know
we'll get through it
so this one is this one's close man this
one's close
you're in the desert i got you you're in
the desert it's night time there's
skeletons out in the desert
i think
what i would like to see with this one
is
your castle on the right i feel like you
want to put the castle at the base of
the mountain
because you have
it's dangerous out at night right
it's dangerous i want to be moving
towards a safe place
so
i'd put my castle
in the middle so the characters walking
towards the castle
and
and that'll give it more of like a kind
of bring it together i also i like how
you do you do have a castle up here but
i want to see like a city down at the
bottom
up at the top is the king you know
um
i think your render quality
um maybe these skeletons i think it's
the lighting yeah the lighting i'm not
sure what's causing this yellow
lighting here on our character maybe
it's from up here i don't know maybe
there's a campfire that would help help
give me the idea that there's some light
here it looks like you're lighting it
from the top though so i'm missing
i'm missing the justification on the
lighting for this
also the background is very low res you
need a higher res star map
um and i think you just need a bit more
a bit more work on your foreground
to give it the realistic kind of feel
that you would need
to really make this come together i
think if you spent another another week
on this you can make it feel complete
but good work
good work everybody
all right so this one
i don't know where we are
and it feels very noisy to me
but the character walking towards a you
know mountain it's glowing getting
brighter all right cool a little washout
um
it feels
there's a lot of colors i really wish
you'd change out the character i wish
the character be switched out
um
it feels too flat to me
i'm missing depth
and i don't
again don't really know where we are
is this like a cyberpunk
video game you know like cyberpunk kind
of vibe
if so then it's an actual place like
it's the sky i think it's the dark blue
sky that gets me i'm like where am i i
don't know where i am
it makes me feel like oh it makes me
feel scared and weird
yeah i mean there's not technically
anything wrong with this render i think
it's just more of a style thing i'm more
into like the realistic style
um
whereas this one has like a lot of like
80s retro kind of feel to it
again i could see a lot of these working
in a music video you know
but as a standalone i'm not sure
where we are that's the only thing i'm
not sure where we are
so again
my
piece of advice would be to
reference use reference
what are the reference images you're
going for
with this kind of image
all right
this is jacked up you got a dude holding
the dude's arm this is like mannequin
hell
no mannequin's land
um
super creepy yeah love the fog
the factories in the back
mountain in the back it's like a little
hard to see a little tough to see you
got some god rays go coming in
some trees
now the only thing
i like how you justified the base model
you know it's a lot of it's mannequin no
mannequin's land all over the place the
only thing that i think is lacking from
this is detail in your foreground and
your mid ground it feels barren it feels
it feels too barren like does this need
to be a swamp does it need to be
salt flat i don't know
i like your dynamic light though it's
moving around this one gets the level up
you got the fallen ashes i like it
oh this is the guy that i'm talking
about for the uh
you remember that art station one the
art renderer where the guy was on the
desk this is the model i'm talking about
so this is freaking creepy this this
reminds me of some sort of creepy album
art as well
salvador dali
uh kind of stuff going on
it's very creepy
to me again it's like
it's like eighty percent foreign twenty
percent familiar but ninety percent
foreign this one is super creepy
but not bad you know um
[Music]
your background is painted i like that
the painted background is cool your
super creepy
face for the mountain
um
hmm
yeah it makes me feel
very lost and confused is how i feel
looking at this which is good you know
it's a feeling that you get when you
look at something so that's that's all
right
it's just a little crazy personally
style wise not my favorite style
but i see what you're going for most
definitely
it'd be nice to see these ants animated
it'd be nice to see that maybe the
clock's drooping down a little bit more
everything just feels a little static if
you can give it a little bit of
animation if these guys were walking
that'd be awesome
maybe if this thing was talking
it could be cool
yeah i'm just missing i'm missing those
things it needs like
a little bit more animation the lighting
is creepy to me like i think maybe needs
a bit more fog or something
um
[Music]
some atmosphere but technically there's
nothing wrong with this
i think this could be freaking awesome
album art definitely
so this one actually happened to just be
an image
unfortunately it didn't come in as a
video and i tried pulling it up but it
just didn't work same for this one here
it just came in as
an image
all right here we go so this
is definitely a foreign land
but there's something about this one
that i actually really like
so
i like your colors and i really like i
think it's it's your atmosphere you're
using your atmosphere in a really nice
way
that breaks this
up and i like your neon glowy kind of
vibes here like this feels cool to me i
really do like this
of again i think this one tops it of all
the other worldly renders now this one
is the new new this one i like this one
a lot
this one's good
your hdri in the back your stars are
actually high res
that's good
i like your green fog here i think this
is cool
and like the bugs flying around i feel
like you definitely use the reference or
some sort of reference with this
well maybe a little bit of
a little bit of halo or something
so i like this this gets the level up
for me
this one is nice i like this one a lot
your render quality is very good
i love your lighting
and the placement of your assets are
really nice and i just i love the style
the western style
and this feels fun to me you got some
dust in the foreground some papers
flying around
your windmill i feel is like a little
small
but maybe that's just the way they are
yeah your lighting's good i like the
mesas in the back your train going
through the mountain i like this one
this one's good this one gets the level
up
so this one this one to me
feels a little too simple
and incomplete
i think you
you know are definitely going for the
desert vibe but i think
in order to get this one to look right i
think you really need to nail the
photorealistic ground because that's
really all you're going for in the
mountain so you have to pull up
reference imagery
and and lighting imagery and lighting
reference first for this stuff to make
it look real
um maybe the end of
lethal weapon
i think there's a scene like this i mean
definitely star wars obviously the
opening of star wars
i forget which one
but the one with luke was it a new hope
i can't remember the one with luke
you know
staying with uncle ben
um
with his uh servant droids out in the
desert
definitely give that a look and a
reference here but
i think it's your character you know i
think it's the the character
model
doesn't feel realistic it feels like
some just diffuse textures
and then
your
your tie fighter coming in
feels
it feels like a lot it feels like a lot
because
i think your whole scene is so simple
but
yeah i just keep working on your render
quality on this one um
[Music]
again if you're going for realism i
think this is nice if you're like going
for like a cartoon style i think this is
pretty sweet
but it just feels like it's lacking a
little something like maybe you need
some village or something or some huts
off in the
background maybe you need
some lights going on but up in the
mountain or something but i think the
the tie fighter is just a bit much for
me personally
we're almost there guys
almost there
this one is incredible this one's a 10
out of 10
complete render
absolutely amazing i love everything
that's going on here the render quality
is fantastic your lighting is fantastic
your animation with the with the train
going by is fantastic you got your
motion blur on it
your snow coming down is incredible
the the the quality on
the graffiti is great you have your
blender you know shout outs you got your
donut i love it
amazing
um
yeah your lighting is so good and you
even have a sim
for the feet down here in the snow which
is really good
um but it's funny because the sims
starts when the characters start so it
must the character must have been
standing there for a long time before he
started walking
um you even have a sim going on the
train with the
with the snow and then out the back
there's this fog
i'm i'm a fan now you used real smart
motion blur it looks like post motion
blur because look at this motion blur
it's broken up i know that i know that
look
you can't get away with that
come on just render motion blur out of
your program it's it's better it's way
better that way
but it doesn't detract from the overall
image you got some dudes down here you
got some cars driving by
10 out of 10.
this gets the
the level up
this reminds me of the storybook stuff
in ghost of tsushima a little bit
this is interesting really interesting
style
um
because this guy has like a force field
or something that kills all these guys
some clouds in the sky
i don't know why the
mountain is moving like that the shade
on the mountain the clouds definitely
moving around but i don't know why
that's moving
this is interesting i think the style
stylizing this helped you stylizing this
definitely helped you without i think it
would have been it would have been a
hard one
um what would i do to make this better
uh maybe
a ground plane of some sort leading up
to the mountain
i feel like the force field is the only
thing that doesn't fit the force field
does not fit you have like a weird
displacement kind of not weird but it's
a displacement thing you have going on
but everything else is sketched in this
is computer generate it feels like
computer generated whereas the rest
feels like
sketched in you know
but that one's not bad i'll give it the
level up
i think it deserves it
this one i believe we talked about i
think i got the level up
talked about these
oh
all right
this is amazing look at the render
quality on
this it looks it looks real it looks
legit
your character design is great walking
towards some sort of aura in the
background
your composition is great
your fog and your lighting is great
this is very well done very very well
done
your
your ground plane is absolutely
incredible it's perfectly
put together perfectly sculpted
perfectly created like you have a lot of
different variation in your rocks in the
ground here i think you killed it
absolutely killed it and it's simple
enough
and it's guiding my eye towards the
center i think it's great definitely
gets the level up for me
this one interesting
very nice got some good trees some good
grass got the wind going through the
grass
space city
got roller coasters going around this
thing
i like this loop i think this loop is
nice it loops all the way around i just
don't know what it is and i don't know
what this orb is
but do i need to know
i don't know
interesting character here looks like a
hazmat suit
you got some lens distortion here
this one's not bad you know um for a
foreign environment for a alien
landscape i i like this one this one
gets the level up for me
all right and the rest i think are
duplicates
yep
okay so guys we
have made it through every single render
oh my god i have to pee so bad
okay so
here's what's gonna happen
i'm gonna take these
all these ones that leveled up and i'm
going to go through
and we're going to level them up again
but we're going to do it a lot faster
and over the next 10 to 15 minutes
i'm just going to start leveling all
these different ones up
until we get
to the final winners and i'm going to go
through and i'm just going to freaking
plow through
until we get to like maybe the top 10
top 20.
and then we're gonna call it all right
we've seen them all i don't need to get
into them too much anymore
i can get into the finals and why i
think they've won
but let me just compile all these real
quick
and then i'm going to use the restroom
and we're going to come back and we're
going to figure out these winners
all right we've got about 40 of them
i am excited
i do the lightning round all right guys
so bear with me
i shall return
wait vfx wizard you didn't you didn't
see yours okay
um
[Music]
vfx wizard i know you're on discord
so let me let me see here
i got you vfx wizard i got you
um
send me
your video
um
and seb chen oh we literally just
finished while reviewing the unfinished
heck yeah
awesome awesome okay
i think yeah there was one there was one
more
there's actually two that i'm still
waiting for permissions for but you know
it's tough
vfx wizard if you could send it to me
send me your uh
oh here's one i missed
i don't want to miss it guys here we go
send it to me on discord
because this is it this is the final
chance here
let me see we got one more to review
here we go
all right i don't want to miss anybody
don't want to miss anybody
sweet yeah
good character model solid character
model
um it feels a bit noisy to me in the
background maybe that's heat ripples i
don't know but the overall thing feels a
bit noisy
so maybe just maybe you can throw a
couple more samples into it next time
your foreground so your foreground
elements i think are a little low res
but maybe that's all your computer could
handle
so i can't judge too harshly you know
um i like this though i like your
lighting it feels nice to me
it feels peaceful
you have some
some it looks like spaceships flying by
so that's the only thing that's given me
the feeling of
if it's kind of like a sci-fi vibe to it
um
and you got a railroad which is a little
low res i think you need to get some
more polys in there
definitely get some more polys but again
maybe you made it work with the polygons
that you had at your exposure
or disposal
but yeah this is not bad it's not bad at
all this i'll give this the level up
congrats
sorry i missed you um
if i did miss you send me your link in
the discord vfx wizard
it says it's sending okay
i'm gonna use the restroom i'll be back
hopefully it's sent by the time i get
back um i'll be back in like two minutes
so i'll see you guys in a second take a
short break
and we're gonna keep leveling up until
we get to our final renders guys
hopefully we'll do it in the next like
20 minutes or so
so i shall return
i hope you guys are enjoying the montage
here
i cannot wait to put all these together
into a really cool
video i think it's gonna be awesome so
it got really bright i need to turn down
my iso hold on
ah
that's better
all right last one guys
vfx wizard got yours coming in
oh boy
very nice
definitely gets the level up
dude
[Music]
god dang dude that is
good that is good
shoot
that's a solid render right there man
love it
absolutely love it this is freaking
great
geez
10 out of 10 dude 5 stars
i don't know i don't have much to say
that's just freaking great man congrats
shoot yeah you got the level up
absolutely
so let's
let's do the work that needs to be done
this is a hard time this is hard guys i
gotta i gotta come out with basically
five winners for prizes who are in the
us and three winners
for international but
i think what i'm gonna do
is just pull the ones that i think are
the best ones
and that'll be like the international
version and then basically we'll go back
and we'll find the ones that are us
eligible for the prizes and we'll
announce the five winners for that
you guys want to see my render okay
here's mine
this is the one i put together
and i talked about what went into this
render at the beginning of this stream
um
now i still have some things that i want
to do to tweak it and whatnot
i want to add a bit more
a bit more smoke up here and maybe cut
the uh
the darkness on this side these birds
are
the frame rate on these birds are a
little off i'm going to tweak that but
i'm super happy with the overall render
freaking love it i think it works great
and the whole scene was running smoothly
for me and everything too so like i'm
really happy with the performance that i
got everything i photo scanned myself
photo scanned uh
my my fiancee's little penguin and i put
that in there too so it's got that
personal personal element to it you know
um
so i'm really really happy with how that
one turned out
so
let's go through these and let's start
leveling some some of these guys up a
little bit more all right
so no hard feelings if you guys don't
get the level up everyone's
everyone's a winner here you know what i
mean you all put in the hard work and
you learned something all right
so let's go through and just start
leveling them up
this one
definitely level up
i can just tell you right now
that gets a level up this one
i feel like these get level ups but let
me just see let me just see
i might have to go through this a couple
a couple times
i think this one definitely
this one definitely gets a level
oh my god you kidding me
level up
absolutely
is it even a question
level up
both of these guys
boom
come on get up get up
get up on the timeline
uh burke hey thanks for the super chat
um
he says thanks time for doing this
you've made learning fun and i owe a lot
of products to you and last discord
absolutely man yeah it's got to be fun
we got to keep learning fun man because
we don't get better until we learn you
know we got to keep learning
so we're going through
these uh this is a level up this is the
level up for sure
we are choosing the winners
and it's a tough process
oh that one oh it's good this one level
up yeah level up
i like that one a lot i gotta level it
goes up to the next level
this one are you kidding me
next level
that one's really good it's really good
and i hear you you got your your full
render complete on this one so that's
awesome i'm glad you did it i'm glad you
did it
um all right this one this one
i'll let this one level up
absolutely this one level up
god that one's so good it's so good
soto i'm sorry
i see you though i see you
oh my god level up
definitely
definitely level up i love that one
dude this one's so sick
level
this one's really good i gotta level
that one too
i freaking love this one
level that one up
this one's really well done level that
one up too
ah that one's really that one's really
good that one's really
good i love this one man i freaking love
this one i'm gonna love this one
level up
ah man that's that's tough that's tough
that's so tough
gah this is difficult this is really
really difficult guys
i think this one gets the level
i like this one a lot this one gets the
level two
this one is not even a question
gets the level up
dude yup this one absolutely level up
and this one
it gets the level up all right so
we did about half
we've got about half of those
leveled up now it's time to take these
and figure out which one of these
goes to the next level
this is difficult
this is a difficult process
all right
so
which ones go
to the next level
oh boy
this one
this one has to
this one has to go to the next level
all right yeah next level
next level this one
is the lighting is incredible
this one has to be the next level
i think this one's next level
i really dig this one i think this one
is
is next level
god this one's good too
next level for
samurai
all right next level for this one
next level
this one definitely is the next level
um all right vfx wizard
where are you from are you from the u.s
all right
so it comes down
[Music]
to these guys
right here
god that is so good
all right
this is this is it this is like top 10
top 11.
top 11 renders right here
so what i'm gonna do here is basically
i'm gonna truly choose the top three
but that does not mean that you win the
prizes so i need because the prizes are
for us only and i need to make sure that
these guys are us only now
i've done this process before
i chose the winners last night
so i need to make sure and i made sure
that
these renders
were from the us so here's what i'm
gonna do here's what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna put this screen
[Music]
over here
so you can't so i don't give away the
winners yet but i have the winners
chosen
so i just want to make sure
that i get this right
because i
don't want to have to go back on all
this with the us and the
the international and makes it tricky
so bear with me here
um
and then i'll go ahead and i'll just i'm
going to play you guys a quick
montage
of
of some of the renders here
while i while i've settled this and
figure this out because we're doing this
once i want to go back on anything here
you
tough decision
tough tough decision
bear with me
you
all right guys
i think i've got it
it's time to announce the winners of the
parallel dimensions
render contest
oh boy that was tough
all right all right all right all right
all right
i'm still
i'm still like oh my god which one
which freaking one
yeah
all right we're gonna work backwards
here
we're gonna work backwards everybody is
everyone
ah is everyone ready
give me some thumbs ups
and it's it's time to announce these
winners
geez
all right
i'm nervous i'm nervous man
huh
all right
okay
okay okay okay
so how do i do this without
all right i'm going to write it down
because i want to reveal it
properly here
all right guys
so
i keep starting okay okay let me just
write this down i'm going to write this
down and i'm going to say it
bear with me bear with me
all right
and then for
international
okay
let's do this
okay here we go
this is it guys
so it comes down to these 11 renders
um i'm going to choose
five winners
for
us only because only people in the u.s
can
win the prizes from pny and nvidia
and then what i'm gonna do is choose the
top three
um
winners that i think
uh deserve something from uh
international so you international guys
i definitely have to give shout outs to
you guys so i'm just gonna be sending
you guys um some photo prints some
signed
you know big prints from me you guys can
choose whichever one you want okay
all right so
let me get the prize pool
going on here
make sure i get these prizes right and
we're gonna do a thing
all right so
let's start with the us in fifth
place
in fifth place
for the parallel dimensions contest
you're going to be winning
a
this is an honorable mention fourth and
fifth place honorable mention
a 256 gigabyte elite x
usb 3.1 flash drive you know don't lose
it because it's about the size of my
thumbnail
um but it's 256 gigs it's got you on
your vfx assets your 3d assets pop it
into any computer you want
and
you know it's there
so in fifth place
we have
dun dun dun
ah it's down here
it's down here
where are you my friend
where are you my u.s domestic
prize eligible friends so many of you
that were from out of uh the united
states
where's your render
i'm gonna find you
bear with me
where the heck did you go bud
there you are here is the winner
boom fifth place
august
you freaking won it dude fifth place
congratulations
i love this render man i love it how's
to has two sides to it
and i love the world that it's in i
think it's great your character's
wounded he's bleeding
but you made it you got fifth place that
flash drive
is coming at you all right so
the team members over at p and y they're
gonna be in touch congratulations on
winning you're the first winner right of
the parallel dimensions contest great
work
great work man i freaking love it super
sick
all right all right all right all right
fourth place
all right we got fourth place it's
another honorable mention
someone who i think did a really good
job someone who
happened to play with scale in a really
interesting way someone who got the uh
the subsurface scattering correct on a
certain little insect
fourth place honorable mention
goes out to
where are you where are you where are
you where are you where are you there
you are
danny
danny boy
congratulations dude
i'm sending a flash drive to you
256 gigs 3.1
dude good times congratulations danny
for winning this one man
honorable mention i think this is
absolutely incredible you did an amazing
job um you got the scale perfect
and you did it in a very interesting and
fun way you took this
idea into a really unique area that i
thought was amazing so
congratulations to you my friend
you're getting an awesome flash drive
all right all right all right now
to
third place
goes to
let's see if we can find him
bam this is our third place winner right
here
now if i could find you
in media pool
and then
maybe find you
in browser
i would know your name is cole stanley
and you just got
third place
in the parallel dimensions contest you
have just won if these numbers mean
anything to you a cs 2130 m.2 nvme one
terabyte ssd
boy you're gonna be rendering things
much faster you're gonna be pull up
files much faster congratulations we're
sending in an ssd your way the pny team
will be in touch
congratulations on your render i love it
look at this
your render quality is fantastic and not
only did you render an awesome
environment you rendered two awesome
environments and piece them together in
a really cool way
like two or three other people did this
two people did this maybe
and you executed very well on it so
congratulations to you my friend to cole
for winning the parallel dimensions
contest
third place
heck yeah all right guys
next up
we got second place that comes after
third place
so in second place this person will be
winning an nvidia shield tv pro it's
basically a sweet thing that you hook up
to your tv and you can like up res all
of your
all of your stuff and you know hook up
your playstation hook up everything to
it um it's a central hub made by nvidia
for your tv for your entertainment
center
second place
now i'm glad this person got me their
render in time
and boy they cut it down to the freaking
wire
um
i guess i may have just missed their
download
and
it happens to be mr vfx wizard with this
incredible
render
look at this thing dude
i'm so glad you got this in front of my
eyeballs
because
you almost got first place man
straight up almost got first place
that's what it was taking me a while i
was because i saw this and i was like oh
crap
this is really good i didn't want to
skip this man i feel so bad if like you
delivered and then i forgot or i didn't
forget
i just i didn't get the download there
were so many downloads i must have you
know forgot one
congratulations mr vfx wizard
um
second place man holy crap this is
absolutely incredible
the work that went into this is
mind-blowing you got
so good so good look at the render
quality on this man is unbelievable
you you earned it man congratulations
i'm glad that i got to see this dude
congrats
oh man
absolutely wonderful now guys that takes
us down to the first place
first place in the u.s right these are
prize eligible
contestants i'm splitting it up into two
because i know there's a lot of amazing
renders that still i think deserves
something so i'm going to break the that
up into
the top three as well this is us only
eligible
and that goes
to not
to none other
than
mr
space
man
congratulations on first place
mr christopher
i'm blown away i am blown away by the
photo reel render quality that you have
here
and do not only that but
your composition your lighting
the story you're telling literally
everything that goes into this
is first place
freaking quality dude i love this render
so much
you absolutely deserve first place
what more can i say man
the quality on this
is is next level it's top tier
you want it congratulations you're
getting the quadro rtx 4000
from nvidia all right we're going to be
in touch with you guys who won prizes we
are gonna be in touch we're gonna get
you guys prizes sent out all right
so congratulations to the us
prize winners
now i could end it here and say
i'll see you guys later but i i felt
very bad that it was a u.s prize pool
only i didn't want to
forget my international folks there's a
lot of them you know there's a whole lot
of you guys so
i want to send you photo prints from me
um they're professionally printed
archival print
and let me just show you real quick you
guys know i have a print shop
and what i'm saying here is that you
guys
can pull any image you see on this
website not just the ones in the store
but the ones
on the main home page or in the
collections they're all the same
go through find an image you love
and i will print it out super nice
on any size you want on the website i
have a big size and a smaller size and
i'll send it to you i'll sign it
give you some music recommendations
um just to show that i you know i care
about you guys and the hard work you're
putting in i want to make it worth your
while so any picture that you love
i got you okay i'll ship it out to you i
don't care if you're from
timbuktu which is actually a place i
will send it to you i don't care
free shipping free everything
i'll make sure you guys get it alright
so
the three
the three international winners that i
think truly deserve this starting with
third place
we have
dun dun dun dun
dun dun dun dun dun dun dun
done dun dun
this one right here
this one right here dude this one's so
good
look at this
absolutely incredible
you built out a world that i want to
live in that i want to be in i want to
be in this little house right off to the
right
right in here maybe maybe this one right
here so i can see the mountain
and i just want to chill here
dude your fog your atmosphere your
character your rendering your lighting
your composition the world the story
the details everything you put into this
is so good
oh so so so so good so congratulations
i'm gonna be sending you um an art print
i know you're on
i think i think this is seb chen
i'm pretty sure this is seb chens or
seba chin
i'm pretty sure
so just hit me up on discord
let me know the print you want i'll send
it out your way man congratulations you
totally deserve it
absolutely incredible
second place
all right i mean i guess it's a second
place you know i'm just i'm just handing
out some uh some prints
for second place we have
our boy right here this one is so
freaking cool
i love this so much
it's unique
it has
a bunch of different colors and style to
it
i love the animating on the twos with
the smoke
this is a show that i want to watch i
want to see this i want to know what's
going on with this giant freaking
electrical thing up here
i want to know where this character's
going i want to know where this
character's been through
this render is such a breath breath of
fresh air with all the realistic renders
that people have been putting in it's my
favorite style but this style here man
has probably got to be my second
favorite style
um the detail work you put in
it's incredible it's absolutely
incredible so congratulations to you
i'll be sending you a print so hit me up
on discord please please please hit me
up on discord
because this is absolutely incredible
i think you deserve it and i hope it
made your day i hope it made i hope it
made your guys's day
and lastly
this is uh
my personal
personal favorite render
out of all of these
and is the final the last winner of
the parallel dimensions contest
it's got to be mr visual
with this one right here
this is so good
let me get into
why i think this is the greatest because
your lighting is impeccable
i love you have a certain softness to
your renders that i don't i don't know
what it is but you have a certain
softness to your managers they're
incredible
your character matches the environment i
think it's wonderful absolutely perfect
you have particles moving through the
air snow particles so i feel cold
just reviewing this
and you have this misty ground layer
that's coming through
right in here right between these like
this little village
that
is so well done
it really adds depth to the entire scene
the particles add depth to the scene and
the flags going from these buildings
really really tell the story and give
you a feeling of like
what it feels like to be in this
environment it shows that there's wind
you're showing that there's wind with
those three things
incredible absolutely incredible
um yeah your lighting is perfect
you're breaking up your character
with the shadow highlight shadow
highlight in the mid ground
um perfect choice of color here orange i
think it's
absolutely wonderful it gives this just
a nice warmth to it even though it's
cold or cold the scene
and what is with that snake in the
background dude it's crazy i love it
it's so creepy it gives it that extra
element
your render quality is always incredible
you really spent time and built out this
environment
so congratulations to you mr visual
i'll be sending you a print just let me
know which one you want man seriously um
congratulations to all the winners
so what i'm gonna do with this guys
i'm gonna take all of these renders
and i i think i'm gonna really include
them all because i don't think it's fair
to just say oh the top 20.
i want to compile everyone's work into
an awesome audio visual montage
my friend casey he's writing music for
it right now it sounds incredible i
can't wait to put it together it's
coming out next week next saturday
before the live stream probably at 9 00
am
i'm gonna put together the whole montage
upload it for you guys and just give
shout outs to everyone who put hard work
in to this whole thing
and i think nvidia is going to share it
and pny is going to share it too
it's going to be a big deal
it's going to be a really big deal so
i'm very very excited super amped to put
that together guys so thank you thank
you thank you so much for putting in all
the hard work
and and really making this contest
special because the contest was only as
good as your guys as renders
and it made it really difficult to
choose all these winners um i hope
everyone's happy
at the end of the day
i hope you guys are content with the
choices that i've made
and i hope you guys have learned
something along the way while doing this
i know i learned i learned how to how to
do weight painting i learned how to do
photo scans
um
i learned how to
make concept art
i learned how to do you know i learned
how to do that fog card technique i
didn't know that one before
i learned how to make
you know smoke and after effects look
like it was glowing from the inside i
didn't know how to do that before like i
learned a lot of things during this and
i hope you guys did too
and shout outs to to this top 11 here
like it was so hard to choose the top
three like these these are so good
i'm blown away
at how awesome these are
this one this one especially man i wish
ah this one's so good
god yeah i'm just so happy with
everything guys thank you so much
christian thanks again for the super
chat man
i see you i hope i didn't miss any i'm
scrolling up i think we're good
um
man that was incredible absolutely
incredible so
we got our winners chosen
i want to say that uh
on next week's stream there's another
big announce announcement i have for you
guys one more
one more big announcement that i can't
talk about yet but next week on saturday
same place same time i got a big
announcement for you guys so definitely
don't miss it all right and it involves
all of you
so
definitely join me next week
um and that's when i'm going to be
putting up the audio visual montage set
the cool music
i'll make sure everyone's names are in
there
it's going to be a good time
um
yeah um yeah i don't know any other
questions that you guys have
i'm here i'm reading the stuff
yeah you guys learned a whole bunch you
learned how to rely on mega scans
absolutely
yeah i'll make sure all
credit all the all the credit goes to
everyone who made this stuff so when i
put out the final video all the credit
will be there no sense in uh
no sense and and not including that
stuff all right
topher is going to post some bts on his
instagram friends interested
heck yeah
the winner
is the winner chris is it christopher i
don't know christopher schultz
i think you're the number one aren't you
i am so glad that you guys enjoyed these
oh man what's next week's challenge
theme oh my god guys
i hadn't thought about next week's
challenge
oh
that's the one thing okay what do you
guys want to do
what do you guys want to do um that's
hilarious yeah what's honey i forgot i
totally forgot about it
can i play the whole thing once for you
guys yeah let's do that let's play the
whole thing once for you guys
let me just grab all of these there
might be some duplicates but that's all
right
um
i'm gonna lay it all out for you guys
and we'll go out to this it's about six
minutes long
all pieces together and we i can answer
some questions for you guys
while we watch it together
and you can see how they all cut
together it's really cool to watch them
all watch them all move together
and lastly
we got these two guys
all right here we go let's go on the
journey together
seriously though thank you guys so much
for making this special i really had a
good time doing this and i was so
excited to see everyone put
all the hard work into all these things
man it was so cool
yeah the egyptian one man i was a huge
fan of the egyptian one
really loved it and the train one was so
good ah so good
professor what's the best way to learn
lighting
i think the best way to learn lighting
is is
if you like an image
save it on save it right put it aside
and ask yourself how they lit it
where's the light coming from and how
can i do that in my renders
if you're outside one day and you say oh
the lighting's really nice take a
picture of it and ask yourself why is
the lighting nice where's the sun coming
from
um
you really just need to ask questions
take pictures
store reference imagery
and
ask yourself where is the lighting
coming from why does it look good
and then mess around you have to do it
so hop in your 3d program and start
making things look nice start messing
with lights and experiment i think
that's really the best way to do it
um or
click the skill share link in the
description below get you know a free
trial of skillshare premium
and uh and look up lighting they have
lighting courses and stuff on skillshare
so definitely give it a shot
yay big fans from india thank you so
much thank you so much one day i will
visit i promise i'll visit one day
uh ooh okay theme for this week's
challenge realistic lighting
i could be down for that
realistic lighting like a like a still
life kind of thing
yeah william one rule don't light from
the front unless you're american apparel
and you like that kind of style
it has its place
um
a flashlight from the front can really
be a cool look
um i know beeple does it sometimes like
with his like pikachu in the cave it's
all front lit just from a flashlight and
it looks awesome it has its place but i
agree
front lighting makes it all flat and
whatnot um eric yo thanks again for the
super chat man
um defense up heck yeah an extra bucha
outstanding display of fairness and
character sweet really enjoyed seeing
the contest thank you sir i really
appreciate you
yeah brandon dude your egypt scene was
sick man it was like i'm so glad i'm not
glad i'm really sad that like it was
such a difficult
choice um but the egypt scene was
beautiful i loved it man great great
work seriously
um
visual heck yeah dude thanks for the
super chat brother thank you so much for
doing this clint not just a challenge
with these weekly challenges of truly
creative community i'm proud to be a
part of heck yeah man
me too i'm really glad that you guys are
a part of this thing
visual your vendors are always top-notch
man like
absolutely incredible
um hands down like you're very very
talented and i'm glad that it's a place
for you to keep making cool stuff so
dude
your render is killer absolutely killer
christian yeah tell a story with the
lighting absolutely
william you say hey clint i'm 13 and
started with blender two years ago i
really got inspired watching you guys
make a slingshot video just wanted to
thank you
thanks for the shouts william appreciate
you man
vfx wizard i'm glad you got it in too
you literally got second place like you
almost got first place it literally
almost happened
it was that close dude
oh my god griffin who won
um
mr christopher won
let me let me show you guys here
so who won so for anyone just joining us
this one is our first place
this is first place international
these ones are just freaking good
renders
this one
third place international
second place international
um
fourth place
runner-up us
this is just a good render
believe this got third place
in the u.s
this one
[Music]
was is an amazing render that i'm very
sad did not place because it was very
hard choice to make this is our second
place
us and then
our
fifth place
is this one right here by august
really really cool render here
um so yeah those are the winners
and now it's about time for me to head
out guys because i gotta go to corridor
to do this
charity stream so go to node um
youtube.com node
uh or nodegaming you just google it
and i'm gonna go play some video games
with natalie right now for the next two
hours alright so
check me out
at three o'clock in the next 20 25
minutes i'll be rolling up a little late
because i gotta
eat and then go
but um
yeah i'll see you guys on the next
stream
we have to decide the challenge what's
the challenge for today
oh what up sign what else hi
it's cliff sign what up sign cliff help
me take the uh
take this
photo scan
he was the one who took all the pictures
for this
so thank you so much cliff
thank you
um
next week's competition all right
let's decide it really quick what's the
next what's next week's competition what
are we going to render what's the
challenge for this week
do you guys want it to be realistic
lighting
cliff you should join this one too
because i know you just started getting
up in blender
realistic lighting um
oh character portrait
character portrait that's not bad
what do you guys think about character
portrait
you can even photo scan yourself
if you want
and just light it
in a really really interesting way so
focus on lighting
um
uh kalypsi if i'm saying that right if
we do character portrait you can light
it however the heck you want
i think you just have fun with the
lighting
yo cliff you got some fans son
all right realistic lighting over
character portrait um
all right um
movie still recreation
or um
a realistic lighting challenge between
those two
recreate a movie still
or realistic lighting challenge
all right what do we got all right
reel sliding move still
i mean it's close but i think movie
still is going to win
yeah let's do the movie still all right
so this is that's the challenge for this
week
create
a um
any scene or any still from a movie in
3d that's the challenge it could be
anything literally anything whatever you
guys want
so i i gotta run all right i'm gonna
have to update the discord
later actually sodamonte
if you have a second could you update
the challenge
for this week
um recreate a movie still
because i gotta run i gotta go to i
gotta go to node and do this live stream
here
but if it's not up by then i'll update
it uh
you know later tonight or something
but guys thank you so much for tuning in
and sticking around and and joining that
amazing contest i'm so blown away by all
the amazing art that came from that guys
um
so i'll see you guys next week i got a
big announcement for you next week so
don't miss out um and i'm putting out
this whole montage
of all these renders with some awesome
music and i'll be giving out all the
credit to you guys nvidia is going to
share it peeing wise and share it it's
going to be very special so don't miss
me next saturday same place same time
and i'll see you guys on node i'm going
to go play some video games
so i'll catch you guys later
peace